يجب أن نقر بالفشل اللي قاعدين نمر فيه عشان نقدر نعالجه
عدديًّا رائع جدًّا
عندك العربية، وعندك إم بي سي، وعندك روتانا، وشراكتنا مع أوربت
الإعلام العربي هو عبارة عن إعلام سعودي «ماليًّا» لكن ثقافيًّا صفر
ومثلما قلت إعلامنا ما يتعدى منفذ القريات
علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة هذه، أدت إلى أن الناس يعزفون عن التلفزيون
أول ما قُدم التلفزيون عند المملكة العربية السعودية
مظاهرات في السعودية ضد هذا الإعلام
يا رجل النشيد الوطني اللي يُقال في الصباح
أنا أتذكر على وقت الملك فهد، الله يرحمه
اللي يرددونه غير سعوديين
ابحث في قوقل، واكتب
ما أبغى أقول مسجل في أي دولة
إذا دققت عليه بتعرف
أتذكر في إعلان للعلا، جايبين بنت...
واسمح لي أن أتكلم بالطريقة هذه
جايبين بنت تتمغط، حرفيًّا، وسط النخل
يوقا
ويسوّق للعلا
وحدة شقراء وعيونها زرقاء، وقاعدة تمارس يوقا
طقس هندي
حاطها في السعودية بين النخل
هل هذا اللي حطه سعودي الحين؟
إذا بتقدم تجربة مختلفة
تكلم عن أيش اللي يميزني أنا كسعودي
يا أخي مهد الحضارات السعودية
أنت ارجع للتاريخ
لا تخليني أعصب
من ابتسامتك أنا متخيل الإجابة الجاية ما راح تكون متفقة مع «عضوان»
أنت لازم تسبب لي مشاكل الظاهر
لا ما أبغى نسوي مشاكل مع أحد
لكن أبغى أعرف قراءتك للمشهد
ما هو مشروع السعودية الإعلامي؟
هذه يبي لها رشفة من القهوة
هذا سقراط من شركة ثمانية
وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم من قادة الرأي
اللي عندهم أطروحة نقدية حادة على التواصل الحكومي
هو الأستاذ، زيد بن خالد التميمي، خبير في الاتصال والتواصل الحكومي
ضيفنا جمع ما بين خبرة عملية داخل إحدى الجهات الحكومية
وخبرة في القطاع الخاص اللي يُقدم خدمات التواصل للجهات الحكومية
فعنده تشخيص لما يُسميه من وجهة نظره
عدم تصدير الخطاب الإعلامي السعودي
تكلم عن أسباب هذا القصور من وجهة نظرة
ضرب مثال بالتجربة الأمريكية
كيف الخطاب الإعلامي الأمريكي تأثيره قوي على مستوى العالم؟
رغم أننا نعرف أن الخطاب مُنحاز
وخطاب فيه كثير من حالاته غير صادق، لكن له تأثير
فأيش أسرار تأثير الخطاب الإعلامي الأمريكي؟
كيف ممكن نستفيد منها بما يتوافق مع قيمنا
ومع نموذجنا السياسي الاجتماعي؟
ضيفنا أيضًا عرّج على تشخيص لعدة أمثلة في القطاع الحكومي للتواصل
أيش نوع القصور اللي فيها؟
ليش الجهات تًكلّمنا عن إنجازاتها
بينما احنا نحتاجها تكلمنا عن الخدمات المقدمة لنا
وعن كيفية استفادتنا منها؟
ذكر عدة أمثلة في هذا الاتجاه
تطرقنا لبعض الحالات المحددة
مثلًا التواصل عن موضوع التأمين الوطني
وكيف أن كان فيه جدل حول هذا الموضوع مثل الرياض
مشاريع صندوق الاستثمارات العامة، العلا
وغيرها من الأمثلة
اللي كان لضيفنا وجهة نظر نقدية في كثير من هذه الأمثلة
دوري كمحاور أني أطرح الآراء المُضادة لرأي الضيف
من باب إثراء الحوار
وليس بالضرورة إنها تمثل رأيي الشخصي
فهذا مهم أننا نأكد عليه في مقدمة الحلقة
الحلقة لخصت في النهاية
أيش هي خطة أو وصفة العلاج اللي يقترحها ضيفنا
لتصدير الخطاب السعودي؟
لأنه يرى بأن فرصنا في تصدير هذا الخطاب
وتفعيله كنقطة قوة، وقوة ناعمة كبرى للسعودية
فرص هائلة إلى الآن لم تستغل
هذه الحلقة برعاية شركة «صفا»
أما الآن، أترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله، يا أبو سيف، شرفتنا ونورتنا
جعلك تسلم، الله يعافيك
سُعداء باستضافتك يا عم، لأننا...
الله يسلمكم، وأنا سعيد بصحبتكم
عندك مشكلة مع كلمة يا عم؟
نعم عندي مشكلة مع يا عم
أيش مشكلتك؟
بعد سن الأربعين، وما أدراك ما بعد سن الأربعين
كنت داخل بنك، واستقبلني شاب لطيف جدًّا
فطلبت منه يرشدني لخدمة العملاء
فقال لي: تفضل من هنا يا عم
فعُقبها جاءتني صدمة لطيفة
فقلت: أنا كبرك يا أخي
فقام يضحك
فبعد تقريبًا ربع ساعة كنت في السيارة لمدة دقيقة
مسوي وضعية تأمل
أن ترى خلاص تعدينا العمر
والحمد لله، ما زالت الصحة جيدة
مواليد 2000 في نص عمرك، على فكرة
إذا أنت ما أنت مستوعب
صُدمت، ما زلت أستدل بعض الأشياء اللي حصلت لنا أيام الطفولة
فأكتشف أن الشباب في عندهم استفاهمات
قاعدة تطلع في الغرفة، وهذا شيء غير جيد
تدري متى دريت إني كبير
لما بدأت أسمّي باسم الولد واسم أبوه
تعرف فلان بن فلان؟
وأنا أذكر وأنا صغير أشوف الشيبان إذا جاء يتكلم
يقول: تعرف فلان بن فلان
أقول: يا أخي هذا فاضي يحفظ الأسامي
لكن مع السن تبدأ، فلان ولد فلان
فإذا صرت أنت تقول فلان بن فلان فمعناها...
تراك شيبت
الله يحييك، يا أبو سيف، احنا سُعداء باستضافتك
الله يعافيك
أنت جمعت بين خبرتين مهمتين
خبرة التواصل الحكومي من داخل جهاز حكومي
وخبرة التواصل الحكومي من شركات أو وكالات تسويق ودعاية
تخدم وتشارك مع جهات الحكومية في التواصل الحكومي
فأنت عندك العدستين
عدسة من جوى ومن برى
فأنت يمكن أفضل شخص نقدر نستضيفه
ونكسب الحديث معه عن التواصل الحكومي في الفترة الماضية
بمفهومه العام والشامل
وليس كإدارة أو مركز محدد يسمى بالتواصل الحكومي
وخلني أبدأ بمقولة لك
أنت تقول: محتوانا ما يتعدى منفذ القريات
رغم أننا ننفق مبالغ ضخمة
كفيلة بإنتاج أكثر من «تايتنكس» بالجمع
بمعنى أكثر من فلم مثل فلم «تايتانيك»
هذا طرح مرة قاسي على محتوانا، وعلى تواصلنا الحكومي
فراح أبدأ من هنا، وأقل لك: أيش المشكلة؟
أنا لا أرى أنها قاسي، أنا أرى أنه لطيف جدًّا بعد
قاعد أمثل لهم تايتانيكس، ونقول له منفذ القريات
إعلامنا السعودي، أيش أقول لك
اللي مدرك الفرصة اللي ممكن يحققها الإعلام السعودي
يحزن بشكل كبير، ويغضب على الصرف الهائل والإنفاق
والنتائج اللي سيئة
لن أقول غير جيدة، راح أقول سيئة
الإعلام السعودي لو ألخصه في ثلاثة مشاكل أساسية عنده
أول مشكلة أساسية عند الإعلام هو علاقته السلبية مع الصورة
احنا كسعوديين عندنا علاقة سلبية مع صورته
نحن والصورة ما نصلح
حرقنا صور واحنا صغار
قُطع الرأس في كتاب المطالعة
إلى الأمور اللي مرينا فيها من ناحية علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة
الجوالات والتصوير، وجوالات الكاميرا، إلى آخره
وهذه أول مشكلة
ويمكن نمر فيها أنا وإياك، ونطرحها بالتفصيل
الشيء الثاني، طال عمرك، عندنا استراتيجيًّا فشل ذريع
مو عارفين
لا في استدامة في الخطاب السعودي
ولا عارفين حتى نصدره برى
ولا عارفين كيف نوصل للآخرين
وهذا فشلنا الاستراتيجي
وعندنا النقطة الثالثة: فشلنا في تعريف أصلًا وظيفة الإعلام
في بعض الأشخاص اللي جلست معهم
حتى منهم مخضرمين في الإعلام
أنه يرى أن وظيفة الإعلام وحدة
بغض النظر عن السياق السياسي والاجتماعي اللي أنت تشتغل فيه
هذه النقاط الثلاثة الأساسية
اللي أتوقع هم من شلّوا الإعلام السعودي
ومنعوه من أنه فعلًا يحقق الفرصة الكبيرة
اللي ممكن يحققها كإعلام سعودي لدولة ضخمة
ومركز إسلامي لعدد سكان يتجاوز ربع سكان العالم
ومثلما قلت، إعلامنا ما يتعدى منفذ القريات
خليني أنقل وجهة نظر مخالفة أو لا تتفق معك
كان أحد ضيوفنا في هذا الموسم هو «عضوان الأحمري»
نعم
طرحت عليه مثل هذا الطرح لكن يمكن مو بهذه الحدة
لكن هو طرح يُمثل وجهة نظر ناس كثيرين
بأن إعلامنا ما هو قادر يتعدى النقاشات المحلية والتأثير المحلي
فاختلف بشدة
وقال: الإعلام السعودي هو المتصدر في المنطقة
لن تجد بيت عربي إلا وفيه مطبوعة سعودية
أو يُتابع برنامج سعودي
هو أكد بأن الإعلام السعودي هو المتصدر والمتسيّد
باستثناء، يمكن اختلفنا احنا على موضوع الإعلام الرياضي
وهو في الأخير وافقني
بأن «بي إن» هي يمكن رائدة في هذا الموضوع
لكن غير الإعلام الرياضي هو يرى سيادة وريادة سعودية مطلقة
عددية فقط
يمكن لطافتك مع لقاء الأستاذ «عضوان الأحمري»
تخليني أنا أكثر شراسة الحين في الطرح
كل هذا الإعلام الضخم، أيش نتيجته؟
أنا مسافر برى أدرس، يمكن قبل خمسة عشر سنة
السعودية، وكيف يُنظر لها؟
لما أقول: احنا في السعودية عندنا التطور الفلاني؟
يضحك
ما زال التصور السلبي، الخيمة والجمل وبئر النفط
هذا الإعلام الضخم صدر الصورة السعودية للخارج، ولّا ما صدرها؟
يجب أن نقر بالفشل اللي قاعدين نمر فيه
عشان نقدر نحل شيء
عدديًّا رائع جدًّا
عندك العربية، وعندك إم بي سي وعندك روتانا، وشراكتنا مع أوربت
الإعلام العربي هو عبارة عن إعلام سعودي ماليًّا، لكن ثقافيًّا صفر
ما صدر الثقافة السعودية
كل هذا الإعلام نملكه لكن ما يمثلنا
وهذا الإشكال الحقيقي احنا عندنا في الإعلام
خلني أرجع لك لجذر المشكلة
أنا ما أبغى ألوم أشخاص، وأتكلم عن مؤسسات معينة
المشكلة عندنا احنا كسعوديين
ترجع لجذر المشكلة، وعلاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة
من بداية الإسلام
ونزول الوحي على سيدنا محمد عليه الصلاة والسلام
حُرّمت الصور
بسبب الإشكال، وتوجيه العلاقة للشرك، الأصنام والأوثان
وفاهميين العلاقة هذه
أن نقول الصور هذه محرمة سواءً رسم أو نحت
أو حتى تصوير فوتوقرافي
وبدأنا هنا من المنحة أن نبعد عن الصورة
وما كنا محتاجينها
نحن كعرب بارعين جدًّا في الكلمة
وكل الأنبياء يجون للأقوام اللي يتوجهون لهم فيما يُجيدون
فموسى، عليه السلام، في السحر
عيسى في الطب
وجزء من الإعجاز الموجود عند سيدنا محمد عليه الصلاة والسلام
هو الإعجاز اللغوي
فنحن أهل الكلمة، ومبدعين فيها، وفي الوصف
اللغة العربية تمتلك مخزون أكثر من 12 مليون مفردة
لو نقارنها باللغة الطاغية اللي هي الإنقليزية
فما تتجاوز 1.5
كنا رائعين جدًّا
1.5 أيش؟
كلمة، 1.5 مليون
مقارنة بـ...؟
مقارنة بـ12 مليون مفردة، فلك أن تتخيل يا أخي البراعة
إِذا رأيت نيوب الليث بارزةً
فلا تظن أن الليث يبتسم
جيب «ستيفن سبيلبرق» خليه يعطيني نفس الانطباع
اللي أعطاني إياه المتنبي في المعنى هذا، سيعجز
سمو الكلمة العالي هذا
شوف انخفاض تعبيرنا في الصورة
وهنا الفجوة الضخمة اللي الإعلام السعودي راح ينجح
إذا قدر يرفع مستوى الصورة إلى مستوى...
أيش تقصد بمستوى الصورة؟
ما عندنا صورة نقدر نصدرها
أتكلم عن الدراما، وأتكلم عن المسرح
وأتكلم عن القصة السعودية
وأتكلم عن الإنتاج الإعلامي السعودي
ما في
علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة هذه
أدت إلى أن الناس يعزفون عن التلفزيون
أول ما قُدم التلفزيون عندنا في المملكة العربية السعودية
مظاهرات في السعودية ضد هذا الإعلام
أتذكر في نقاش مع أحد الأكاديميين
قال: أنت تبالغ، يا زيد، في علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة
وهذه مجرد فترة معينة وانتهت
لما بدأ التلفزيون
وصار عندنا مظاهرات في الشارع السعودي
وصلت إلى تبادل إطلاق نار
علاقتنا السلبية هذه لها تراكمات منعتنا فعلًا أن ما ندخل التلفزيون
وأزيدك من الطين بلة
عزوف في السعوديين عن العمل سواءً في المسرح أو السينما
علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة خلتنا نبعد عن التلفزيون
إلى أن أدى عندنا احنا كسعوديين اضطرارًا أن نُجل غير السعودي
غير السعودي هذا لما يشتغل الآن في الإعلام
أتاك شخص لا يمتلك تركيبك القيمي، ولا يفهمك أنت
ولديه قيم هو يعتز فيها
هو يدير إعلامنا
ولاحظ عاد المسرحية أو الكوميديا ​​السوداء
اللي مر في الإعلام السعودي
مسلسلات بعدة لهجات، وشيء مبعد عنه
يا رجل النشيد الوطني اللي يقال في الصباح
أنا أتذكر على وقت الملك فهد، الله يرحمه
اللي يرددونه غير سعوديين
ابحث في قوقل، واكتب
يعني انفصالنا تام عن الإعلام
كيف اللي يرددونه غير سعوديين؟
غير سعوديين
ما أبغى أقول مسجل في أي دولة
إذا دققت عليه بتعرف
النشيد الوطني اللي يردده غير سعوديين
عشان تعرف بُعدنا عن الصورة
يا رجل مسلسلات، ونجوى وإلى آخره
ما كان فيه شيء يشبهنا يا السعوديين، حرفيًّا، طول العام
إلا نص ساعة بعد صلاة المغرب في رمضان
«طاش ما طاش» بعض الأحيان
وننبسط ونتجمع عند التلفزيون
واضح العطش السعودي لشيء يمثلنا
لكن لا زال يقدم لنا الإعلام...
لأنه قاعد يُدار من غير سعوديين
وهذه لعنة الإعلام السعودي
أنا ما أنكر فضلهم
لكن هذا منعنا من أن نصدر خطابنا للخارج
فجاءنا هذول الغير سعوديين يعمل في الإعلام السعودي
المسكين ما يفهم ثقافتك
ما هو عارف يمثلك
حاول يشبهك أكثر من مرة، وفشل ذريع
احنا قاعدين نطقطق عليهم الحين
فبدأ يوجه خطابه للحكومة
قاعد يتخيل أن الحكومة هي اللي تتفرج على الخطاب
فبدايةً الخطاب الإعلامي هذا ما يمثلني
أصبح كأنه يكلم الحكومة
ترى أنتم كويسين، وأنجزتم، وسويتوا واحد واثنين وثلاثة
من دون أن يخاطب المجتمع
وفي نفس الوقت للأسف
في الأجندة هذا غير سعودي، وقاعد يمارس وصاية عليك أنت
فأصبح أنه هو يتكلم في البرامج
المفروض أنك أنت يا السعودي تسوي واحد واثنين وثلاثة
عشان تصير سعودي أحسن
طيب على وزن أي قيم؟
على القيم اللي احنا نؤمن فيها، والقيم الغربية
فالإعلام هذا أصبح ما يمثلني أنا بشكل مزعج جدًّا
في نقاش مع أحد الشباب قال: هذا غير صحيح
قلت له: يا رجل، «افتح يا سمسم» الساعة عشرة صباحًا
يتكلم معك بنفس الطريقة اللي يتكلم معك الإعلام بشكل عام
«افتح يا سمسم» أيش يقول؟
يقول: إذا أردت أن تكون ولدًا صالحًا فعليك أن تفعل كذا وكذا
الساعة عشرة المساء البرنامج الإخباري الحواري
إذا أردت أن تكون مواطنًا صالحًا فعليك أن تفعل كذا وكذا
فقاعد كأنه عبارة عن جهاز توجيهي بحت ما فيه أي نوع من أنواع التمثيل
فلاحظ هذا اللي فشل أنه يشبهك أن هذا الإعلام اللي يدار من غير السعوديين
كيف تبيه يمثلك برى أو يرسل خطاب برى؟
إذا هو عجزان أنه يشبهني
أنا أضحك عليه
إذا جاء يقلد السعودي، وشفنا العقال، ويا الله حيه
وإلى آخره من الأمور هذه
فهذا ركن أساسي اللي عندنا علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة
أدت عزوفنا احنا يا السعوديين، وسيطر غير السعوديين على الإعلام
ودخلنا في الدهليز هذا
اللي احنا كدولة مركز للعالم الإسلامي
ربع سكان الكرة الأرضية يتبع للثقافة هذه
خطابنا غير مسموع
فاحنا قلنا المشكلة الأولى: علاقتنا بالصورة أدت إلى عزوفنا
فصارت المشكلة الثانية
أن احنا ما كنا حاضرين فيه، وسيطروا عليه غير السعوديين
هل فيه جذور أخرى لهذه المشكلة؟
للأسف تأثر الكثير من السعوديين
اللي حصل الحين يمكن قبل ثمانية سنوات
طلعت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ويا الله لك الحمد، على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مع إني أكره ما يحصل فيها كثيرًا
لكن هذه أحد الحسنات الموجودة
طلعوا عيالنا، قاموا يطقطقون عليهم، يا أخي احنا مو كذا
ولا نتكلم بالطريقة هذه
ولا أني أضع العقال فوق رأسي بالطريقة هذه
فبدأوا يصحصحون
الآن لما تشوف سلسلة الإمداد كاملة أو سلسلة القيمة حقت الإعلام
بعدين من بحث واستراتيجيات، والمحتوى الإبداعي والإنتاج
نتكلم عن (...)*والفعاليات
إلى البحث اللي يطلع لك الناتج
ما نجحنا إلا في تحرير كتابة المحتوى
كل هذه المنظومة اللي يملكها غير السعوديين
ما ملكنا احنا إلا كتابة المحتوى
تلقى عيالنا في الإبداع
عيالنا، الظاهر السن ما زال موجود
زملاؤنا وأخواننا ما زالوا هم اللي يكتبون الحين في العملية هذه
لكن سلسلة الإمداد إلى الآن ما تزال محتلة
خليني أستخدم المصطلح هذا
ولم نحرر إلا جزء كتابة المحتوى الإبداعي
نجحنا الآن إلى حد معين في تحرير الخطاب السعودي
بحيث أنه يعكس، ويمثلني أنا كسعودي
لكن للأسف إدارة الإعلام أو إدارة التصور عن المملكة العربية السعودية
خارج السعودية ما زال حتى المحتوى اللي يديره غير السعودي
خليني هنا شوي أجرب أتحدى بعض هذه الأطروحات اللي طرحتها
فقط لو تسمح لي أوضح نقطة
أنا مو هنا جاي أتكلم عن إيجابيات
ترى، ما شاء الله، الإيجابيات بالهبل
أنا هنا جاي أتكلم عن مكان ألم
أنا أقول لك: ركبته اليمين تعوره
راح أتكلم على ركبته اليمين
لا تقول لي: ركبته اليسار كويسة، أنا أتكلم عن اليمين
احنا راح نتكلم على ركبته اليمين واليسار
لكن عن الركبة اللي تعوره هذه اليسار
أبشر طال عمرك
راح أقتبس رأي لـ «عبدالرحمن الراشد»
في «فنجان» كان يقول: المفروض ما يكون عندك سعوديين
أكثر من 15 إلى 20%
في أي وسيلة إعلام تُخاطب العالم العربي
أنت محتاج هذا التنوع، ومحتاج هذه النظرة الشمولية
عشان تقدر تقدم منتج يخاطب العربي الآخر
غير صحيح
اعطني رأيك؟
تكلم أنت، أنت قابلت «إبراهيم»
قال لك: إم بي سي المصرية، كم عدد المصريين اللي فيها؟
100%
ترجع للقائك
إم بي سي العراق؟ 100%
إم بي سي السعودية كم؟
أنت قل لي كم؟
ما أدري
بس اللي واضح جدًّا حتى من لغة الخطاب
لما يرد عليك في تويتر أنه قاعد يكلمك غير سعودي
أيش معنى إن طالبت الآن في الإعلام المصري أن يديرونه مصريين
وإعلام الدولة الثانية يديرونه أهل الدولة عشان يمثلونه
ولما تجي للإعلام السعودي تجده مختطف بشكل كامل
وحتى صُناع القرار غير سعودي
لا فقط عشان نعطي الموضوع سياق
«عبدالرحمن الراشد» تكلم على قناة العربية
اللي جمهورها كل العالم العربي
قناة إم بي سي مصر هي موجهة للمصريين
قناة إم بي سي العراق موجهة للعراقيين
وقناة إم بي سي الموجهة للسعوديين
إم بي سي 1 هي موجهة للسعوديين
واللي موجهة للسعوديين؟
هو يرى بأنه تأخر دخول السعودية للقطاع
أدى أنه ما أقدر أعتمد عليهم
ممكن أنه يقول: علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة منعت السعوديين من إنهم يدخلوا
قد أتفهم هذا
وذكر أمثلة أنه كان بعض الموظفين يستقيلون نتيجة ضغط أهلهم
لأنه هذه وظيفة محرمة، ومالها مشكوك فيه أن نشتغل في التلفزيون
صحيح، صدقت في هذا
ففيه تحدي مواهب
اليوم يقول: لما انتقلنا للرياض بدأ الموضوع يصير أسهل
فمتوقع أن يزداد عددها
فقط قاعد أعطي سياق للموضوع
أحسنت
قناة العربية...
يعني قناة الجزيرة حتى لو اختلفنا مع كثير من توجهاتها
هي قناة ما فيها قطريين
الـ«بي بي سي» ولّا حتى «بلومبرق»
راح تلاقي فيهم تنوع في ثقافات الأشخاص الموجودين
فهل أنت قاعد تربط فشل التواصل أو الإعلام السعودي
أو الخطاب السعودي، فقط لأننا متنوعين
وهذول طيب كلهم متنوعين، وقدروا ينجحون؟
حسنًا، فشل تصدير الثقافة السعودية
مختلف تمامًا عن إدارة إعلام يشمل العالم العربي
فصل لي فيهم
فاحنا فشلنا في تصدير الخطاب السعودي لبقية العالم
مع أنها دولة مركز تمتلك امتيازات عالية جدًّا
لأننا نحن السعوديين لا نعمل في الإعلام
هل فيه لوبي الآن يمنع السعوديين ما يشتغلون في العالم؟
هذا شيء ثاني
هل ماليًّا هذا الإعلام مملوك من السعوديين؟ نعم
الآن هذا التناقض بين أن احنا من يملك الإعلام
وأن الخطاب السعودي لم يتم تمثيله
إذا أنت راح تستند فقط على فكرة إنها علاقتنا السلبية مع الصورة
أنا أقول هذا غير صحيح، لا يكفي
لكن هذه انتهت، أبو سيف
أنت قاعد تؤكد إنك أنت أربعيني جاد بالعودة لها
غير جاد
الأجيال الجديدة ما عندها إطلاق...
أنا أصلًا متأكد أن بعض المتابعين الحين يقولون
أيش قصده بعلاقتنا مع الصورة؟
لأنهم في مرحلة نشأوا وولدوا وكبروا وعلاقتنا بالصورة ممتازة
بل احنا ملوك الصورة وملوك السلفي وملوك السناب شات
بطريقة تتناقض مع اللي أنت قاعد تقول له
أنت قاعد تذكر الماضي
نجحنا في تحرير وإعادة تعريف علاقتنا مع الصورة محليًّا
لكن خارجيًّا فاشلين جدًّا
أعطيني محتوى سعودي يُصدر للخارج؟
مع الإنتاج الضخم هذا الآن، كم صرفنا؟
يا رجل الوزرات تصرف مئات الملايين
ليش ما قاعدين نوصل؟
وليش ما قاعدين نوصل؟
قُل لي أنت
أنا ما أعرف، أنت الخبير
لأنها الآن نفس طريقة الطرح الغريبة اللي أنت قاعد تصدر للآخرين
ترى أنا مثلك، أنا أشبهك، ليش ما تجي عندنا؟
ما أبغى أروح أنا أستخدم يمكن أمثلة الحين
لكن خليني أذكر لك بعض الأمثلة
أذكر في إعلان للعلا جايبين بنت...
واسمح لي أن أتكلم بالطريقة هذه
جايبين بنت تتمغضط حرفيًّا وسط النخل
يوقا، ويسوق العلا
وحدة شقراء وعيونها زرقاء، قاعدة تمارس يوقا، وطقس هندي
وحاطها في السعودية بين النخل
هل هذا اللي حطه سعودي الحين؟
هل هذا واحد فاهم أيش الثقافة السعودية؟
تسويق برامج الإنتاج الإعلامي
لما نقول: تعالوا صوروا عندنا أفلام في السعودية
قاعدين نصور أننا نجيب فلم « إنديانا جونز»
«إنديانا جونز» تقدر تصور عندنا في السعودية
في دول عربية طبقت الطريقة هذه
ونجحوا في استقطاب أفلام «ستار وورز»
ونجحوا في استقطاب أفلام حتى إعلام أكبر مثل «جيم أوف ثرونز»
لكن خلوا الدولة عبارة عن خلفيات وكومبارس
أذكر حتى مشهد في «كاريسي» أو «جيم أوف ثرونز»
مصورينه في المغرب
الموجودين في الكومبارس كلهم، أنقذينها يا «كاريسي»
بس إذا أنا أبغى أستهدف السائح الأوربي ولّا الأمريكي ولّا الياباني
هل المفترض إني أحط صورة سعودي يصلي في العلا
عشان أقدر أستقطبهم؟
من قال أنه سعودي يصلي في العلا؟
أجل شلون؟
قدم الثقافة السعودية والمختلف فيها
نحن ما عندنا شيء متميز؟ صفر
لازم أسوي يوقا وعيوني زرقاء، وشعري أشقر، ووسط النخل
عشان أقول له: تعال للعلا؟
أيش المفروض يكون؟ في الحالة هذه مثلًا، اعطنى مثال
يا أخي تعال ابحث عن قصصنا احنا كسعوديين
خلنا نأخذ مثال العلا
راح أعطيك مثال، العلا يا رجل التحف والقصص والتاريخ
العلا تستهدف مثلًا نصف الزوار سعوديين ونصفهم أجانب
السعوديين وصلنا لهم، وسمعونا وعرفونا
ليش الأجانب الغرب الأوربيين فقط؟
أنا أعرف أندية وجهات حكومية إنها تستهدف أصلًا الشرق أكثر من الغرب
تلقى دعاياتهم وإنفقاتهم عندهم في الغرب أكثر من الشرق
لكن أرجع للقصص
اعطني مثال كيف ممكن...
أنا أعطيك، يا أخي، ارجعوا لتاريخنا، وطلعوا قصص
«إِرَمَ ذَاتِ الْعِمَادِ، الَّتِي لَمْ يُخْلَقْ مِثْلُهَا فِي الْبِلَادِ»
يا رجل ما أنت قادر تطلع شيء من حضارتنا وثقافتنا، وتُقدمه للآخرين؟
ما تقدر تبيع السعودية إلا من خلال يوقا؟
هذا اللي تبغانا نقوله احنا صرنا متطورين؟
أتذكر حتى بعض الشركات الموجودة عندنا
تلبس عيالنا فروة بنفسجية، وتخليه يرقص راب
ويطلع هذا وخلاص صدرنا خطابنا للإعلام اللي برى؟
هذا غير صحيح
يا أخي إذا أنت راح تمثل السعودية، وإذا راح تقدم تجربة مختلفة
تكلم عن أيش اللي يميزني أنا كسعودي
يا أخي مهد الحضارات السعودية، أنت ارجع للتاريخ
لا تخليني أعصب الحين
يا أخي معقولة ما حصلنا قصص؟
ترجع أنت في الشيء الاجتماعي
في قصص وخرافات تبيها في الجن
تبي في الطقوس اللي عندنا الرقصات الشعبية والأغاني
عجزت إنك تقدم شيء مميز؟ خلاص انتهى؟
يعني عجزك في بحثك
أنت قاعد تراهن على جهلك
معرفتك في الآخر، وتروح تنسخ وتجي تلصق علي
وتقول لي: أنا قاعد أنقل ثقافتي؟
يعني أنت تجهل القصص اللي عندي؟
ما أنت عارف تقدم شيء متميز؟
أنت فهمتني، يا طويل عمرك، هذا اللي مزعلني
إنك يا أخي ما سويت البحث حقك
ما فيه تميز عندنا؟ احنا شعب خلاص ما عنده أي قصص؟
وهذا المؤلم، يطول لي عمرك
إنك تروح تسوق لي العلا يبوقا
وتجيب لي أفلام «إنديانا جونز»
عشان نصير كومبارس، وخلفيات للأفلام
أنا أزعم بما إني قابلت رئيس هيئة الأفلام
نعم شفت اللقاء هذا
إنك ما تقدر تبدأ من الأخير
يعني أنت عشان تبدأ
ولا تعيد فعل الأخرين، وتتوقع نتائج أخرى
عشان تصير في فلم بطولة وقصته عن العلا تحديدًا
أنت تحتاج سلسلة من التجارب والثقة والارتياح
أبدًا، هذا خطأ وغير صحيح
حق هوليوود بجي مباشرة، ويقول: راح أصور فلم عن العلا
وأبي أبطال سعوديين ما عمرهم مثلوا في أفلام
هل تتوقع يصير كذا؟
لا مو بالطريقة هذه
هم يبغون يصنعون العجلة أو يحركونها
أنا ما أمثلهم بس قاعد أحاول أطرح وجهة نظر
لكن لا تسوق السعودية في خلفية وكومبارس
هذا اللي قاعد تسويه أنت
أيش أصورها؟
قدم، يا أخي، قصص السعودية المميزة
اللي تقدم قصة صراع الخير والشر بطريقة مختلفة
لازم الطرح الغربي؟
لازم تروح أنت هوليوود الآن المفلسة، وعندها حنين للماضي
وقاعدة تجتر أفلامها القديمة هذه
وكلنا قاعدين نشوفها
الحين «سيلفستر » ما شاء الله، خوينا «رامبو»
بما أننا شيبان
قاعد يطلع في أفلام حركة
تكلم عن نفسك لو سمحت، أنا مو أربعيني لسة
طيب، الآن «سيلفستر ستالون»
قاعدين يعانون فعلًا من الحنين للماضي
وقاعد أنت تبغى تجتر معهم؟ غير صحيح
يا أخي شوف التجربة اليابانية
هل قدموا قصصهم بالإطار؟
جزئيًّا نعم مشوا مع الثقافة الغربية لكن قدم ثقافته
طالع كوريا، كم احتاجت عشان تقفز القفزة العالمية هذه كلها؟
ثلاثين سنة؟
يعني لازم تعيد اختراع العجلة من الصفر؟
لو استخدمنا مثال كوريا راح نلاقي بأن أسلوب أشهر الفرق الكورية
نعم
غربي جدًّا، وهذا يتعارض مع وجهة نظرك
هنا الفرق، ودائمًا يحصل في النقاش بينا وبينهم
كوريا ليست دولة مركز فيه ثقافة
وتستطيع أن تصبغ الدولة كلها بلون ثاني، ولا أحد يكلمك
لكن لا تستطيع المملكة العربية السعودية
كدولة مركز للعالم الإسلامي
إنك تقول خلها نسخة من شيء آخر
ما دامك ذكرت هذه النقطة أكثر من مرة
ممكن تشرح لنا مفهوم دولة المركز
طيب، العالم يا طويل العمر، يُقسم تقريبًا إلى سبع حضارات
وكل حضارة لها دولة ومركز
في عندنا الحضارة الكونفوشيوسية اللي هي الصين
عندنا الحضارة الهندوسية اللي هي في الهند
وعندنا الحضارة الإسلامية اللي مركزها في المملكة العربية السعودية
عندنا الأرثودكس، روسيا
والبروتستانت اللي هو في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وأفريقيا وأمريكا اللاتينية اللي هم الكاثوليك
سواء إيطاليا تقريبًا ولا الأرجنتين
في كل دولة مركز هو اللي يسيطر...
أفريقيا عفوًا...؟
أفريقيا، للأسف ما أدري، هو عنصري هذا «سمير هونتينق ديو» ولّا لا
في كتابه «صراع الحضارات» لكن ما كتب لها مركز
لأنها أُستعمرت بطريقة شرسة جدًّا
فهذه سبع حضارات هي اليوم...
الموجودة
والمؤثر فيها هي دول مركز فقط
أذكر كنا في نقاش في جامعة أمريكية
قلنا: نحن من أجل أن يؤثر الإعلام في الخارج
يجب أن يكون الإعلام ديمقراطي
يوم سألنا احنا في أمريكا قلنا: طيب
كيف تصالح بين الديمقراطية والرأسمالية
هذه يمكن نناقشها بعدين لأن ما تصلح أصلًا مع بعض
شركة وديمقراطية ما تجي مع بعض
فدرسنا العملية
هل فعلًا الديمقراطية هي اللي تؤدي إلى تصدير الخطاب؟
فوجدنا أن أكثر دول في العالم برزت ديموقراطيًّا
هي الدول الاسكندنافية
تعرف أيش لغتهم، ولّا سمعت مسلسل عنهم، ولّا صدروا لك ثقافة
لأنها ليست دولة مركز
الدولة المركز هي اللي في فلكها يدور دور الثانية
اللي مزعجني عن السعودية احنا دولة مركز
وما نجحنا أننا نخلي الفلك يتحرك ويدور حولنا بشكل قوي
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أقل ديمقراطيًّا من الدولة الثانية
لكن نجحت كدولة مركز إنها تصدر الخطاب
الصين نجحت كدولة مركز إنها تصدر
الهند نجحت كدولة مركز، والروس نجحوا كدولة مركز
نحن كسعودين كدولة مركز نجحنا في تصدير الخطاب؟
هل ممكن أن السعودية تروح تقتبس من ثقافة أخرى، وهي دولة مركز؟
راح يأثر عليها أصلًا، ويأثر على تعريفها كدولة مركز
وهذا الشيء المزعج أن التطور أنك كيف تكون زي المتطور
ما دامك جبت طاري أمريكا ممكن نتعمق في تجربتها
لأنها كانت هي، وأظن إلى وقت قريب
أفضل نموذج للقوة الناعمة الإعلامية والنفوذ الإعلامي
هي يمكن أفضل، صحيح، وما زالت الأفضل
لكنها يمكن وصلت في منحنى تراجع
عندك رأي بأنها اليوم في حالة تراجع
خلني أعطيك، هناك أركان ثلاثة أساسية لنجاح الإعلام
وهذا اللي خلى الإعلام الغربي ينجح
ترى مو خلاه ينجح هو هوليوود وقوة التقنية ونضوج الصناعة
هذا شيء نقدر نبنيه في أقل من عشر سنوات
اللي حصل، يا طويل العمر، الخطاب الغربي مبني على ثلاثة أركان
يتحدث عن الحقوق
يُرسل لك الخطاب من خلال حوار
ويتكلم لك عن فرص لك أنت
حقوق وحوار وفرص
نعم، لما يكلمك الخطاب الإعلام الأمريكي
خاصةً لما نتكلم عن الثقافة الغربية ككل
دائمًا نتكلم، يحق لك ويحق لك، والمفترض أن يكون لك كذا وكذا
وما أجمل هذا الخطاب يا أخي
اللي قاعد يكلمني أنا
يقول: المفروض إن يكون عندك أحسن من اللي عندك
يا أخي ممتاز
ثم تجي بعد هذا تلقاه يطرح لك في حوار
طيب أيش رأيك؟
طيب احنا خلنا نناقش الفكرة
يمكن هذا قبل هذا، ولّا هذا قبل هذاك
ثم أنا أكاد ألتصق بالشاشة مهما كان الخطاب الأحادي رائع
يظل الحوار هو اللي يجذبك بشكل قوي جدًّا
مع أنه يمشي الأجندة حقته
أنا أتكلم عن أدوات الحين يستخدمها
ثم في الأخير يتكلم لك عن فرص
يقول لك: نزلنا على القمر
ما يتكلم أو يهايط
يقول لك: ترى احنا نزلنا على القمر
ترى احنا من أجل الإنسانية وصلنا إلى القمر
وعندنا البرامج الموجودة مثل ناسا، ودك تجي عندنا؟
فالخطاب الأمريكي مبني على بيع فرص
فلما أنا يا المشاهد أنظر إذا أحد يتكلم لي عني، وما يحق لي
ثم يسألني عن رأيي من خلال الحوار
ثم يقول ترى عندك فرصة إنك تقدر تجي وتكون معنا
كيف ما أنسحر من هذا الخطاب؟
لما يتكلم عن الحقوق، الخطاب الحقوقي يخترق كل الحضارات
بشكل شنيع جدًّا
له أساسيات إن الحرب الباردة
وكيف إن الخطاب الرأسمالي كان يتنافس مع الاشتراكية يمكن
لكن ما أبغى أدخل في تفاصيل هذا الموضوع
لكن هذه الأركان الأساسية الثلاثة اللي بُني عليها الإعلام الأمريكي
وخلاه ينجح
لكن ما أبغى أقول احنا نمشي وراءهم
خلنا نربط فرامل شوي
للأسف من تقريبًا خمسة عشر سنة إلى الآن
وبدأ المنحنى في تنازل، وما زالوا هم الأوائل
لكن خطابهم الآن بدأ في تنازل
الحقوق الشمولية هذه اللي كان يتكلم عنا كلنا
أصبح يتكلم عن حقوق أقليات
وما هو واجبنا نحن ككل اتجاه تلك الأقلية
الشاذين جنسيًّا، ونتكلم عن السود
وصار في عملية سيطرة أو حتى استحواذ على التاريخ
لأن أصبح الفراعنة سود
وأصبح شذود الجنسية يتم إلصاقه في كل شيء
فبدأ يفقد الزخم فعلًا الحقوقي اللي خلانا ننجذب له
ما عاد هو يتحدث عني
هو يتحدث عن غيري، وأيش دوري أنا اتجاه هذا الغير
فبدأ وشفناه
أول ركن، ركن الحقوق، تغير من حقوق...
تغير، وهو ما زال موجود فيه
الأغلب إلى حقوق الأقليات
الأقل جزئيًّا، وما زال موجود فيه كلام عن حقوق الكل
لكن جزئيًّا هو تصدع
الآن الركن الثاني: الحوار، انهارت عندهم الحقيقة
أصبح الرأي عنده أهم من الحقيقة
فعندي حقيقتي، وعندي حقيقتك، وكل واحد يتكلم بطريقة
وشفنا عاد الجندرية، والنقاش السخيف
اللي هو أصبح أضحوكة للعالم قدامنا
لأن يا أخي إذا ما نتفق أيش الحقيقة الموضوعية
إنها هي أساس أصلًا الحوار راح ينهار الحوار
وهذا اللي بخلانا بدأ يفقد زخمه أنه رأيي أهم من الحقيقة
وقمنا نتكلم عن عصر ما بعد الحقيقة بشكل قوي جدًّا
الركن الثالث اللي هو الفرص
الفرص اللي كان يبيها الحلم الأمريكي
وتعال هناك ودرّس عيالك في أفضل الجامعات، وخلك معنا
ما زال جزئيًّا موجود
لكن بدأنا نتكلم عن بناء الحائط
«رهاب الأجانب» وطرد الأجانب بالجملة من البلاد
تصادم وإغراق قوارب المهاجرين
ما نبي المسلمين
حتى أرجع لعملية الحقوق وتصدير...
والإيمان بحقوقنا ككل كبشر
وشفنا في قضيتنا في غزة
وكيف تصدع الإعلام الغربي مصداقيته عندنا
خاصةً في المنطقة بشكل قوي جدًّا
لكن أيش اللي أنقذه؟ بقايا الحوار
الإعلام الغربي للحين يحافظ على الحوار
باسم يوسف وين شفناه فيه؟ شفناه بالعربية؟
«بيرس مورقان»
وشفنا أيضًا الآخرين اللي قاعدين يردون
فهذه الأركان الثلاثة هي اللي حافظت
مع أنه قاعد ينزف مصداقية الإعلام الغربي
لكن تمسكه جزئيًّا بهذه الأهداف حافظت على مصداقيته
وما زلنا نشاهد الإعلام الغربي مع أننا نؤمن أنه عنده أجندة موجودة
دامك لخصتها في هذه الثلاثة أركان
نعم
ونتكلم عن حقوق، حوار، فرص
تعال نمسكها، ونطبقها على التواصل الحكومي
أو الإعلام السعودي
ونشوف أيش واقعنا في الثلاث أركان هذه
نحن عندنا أركان ثانية، وليست المملكة العربية السعودية
أنا لا أتكلم عن المملكة العربية السعودية فقط
احنا نتكلم عن الشرق بشكل عام
الإعلام الشرقي فشل لأنه يعتمد على ثلاثة أركان ثانية
مختلفة عن الثلاثة أركان الأولى، وتكاد تكون النقيض
الخطاب الشرقي يتكلم عن الواجب
يجب عليك، ويجب عليك
وأنت الصالح الكويس اللي يفعل ما يجب عليه
ليش؟ نحن شعوب متدينة، ونؤمن بالحياة ما بعد الممات
وهذه الحياة حياة اختبار
والمكافآت راح تكون وقت الحساب
يا تروح الجنة، يا تروح النار
فهذا خلى الخطاب والواجب يطغى، واختفى خطاب الحقوق
مشكلة خطاب الواجب أنه لا يمكن تصديره
أنا ما أقدر أروح لواحد في ثقافة ثانية
وأقول: يجب عليك كذا، ما تقدر
أنا ما أقدر أتكلم على مستوى الحقوق حتى الكوني
اللي ممكن أقدر أصدره للآخرين
لكن في الواجب يفشل عشان كذا ما تعدينا القريات
يعني خطابنا خطاب واجب
يجب عليك، والمواطن الصالح يجب أن يفعل كذا
وأنت يجب أن تفعل كذا، وكلنا يجب أن نفعل كذا
فالتحاصر في الصين وفي روسيا
كلها الخطاب الواجب تجد إنها تعريف من يلتزم بالواجب هو الشخص الصالح
تعال للركن الثاني: توحيد الخطاب
يقابل موضوع الحوار؟
الحوار، أنا حضرت ورشة عمل فيها نخب من قيادة الإعلام
في القطاع الحكومي والقطاع الخاص
اسم ورشة العمل
ما هي السبل لتوحيد الخطاب، وإبراز الإنجازات؟
أنا صُدمت، وقلت: يا رجل اسمح لي إني أعترض
سبب ضياع الإعلام السعودي هو هذا العنوان اللي أنت كاتبه
كيف توحيد الخطاب، وتبغى تصدره برى؟
أنت لمن تتكلم عن الإعلام الغربي كسلطة رابعة
وأنه أصلًا وجد ككلب مراقب للحكومة، إذا صح التعبير
على حسب تعبيرهم هم، ويتابع الحكومة
أنه يتعامل مع خطاب حكومتهم بالتشكيك
كيف تبيه يتعامل مع خطاب موحد مصدر من حكومة مختلفة
بأنه يكون معنا، ويرحب، وأن يعطينا مصداقية عالية جدًّا
ثم يجيني صاحبي ويقول: انظر كيف يُستقبل الخطاب
أنت شفت كيف فكك خطاب البيت الأبيض؟
شفت كيف يفتتونه تفتيت؟
زعلان أنت لما تصدر طَرد واحد يمثل دولة كاملة
تصدره للخارج ثم تقول: ليش الإعلام قاعد يستقبل بالطريقة هذه؟
شوف الآن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
حتى في موضوع غزة لما يهاجمونها كلها
أحد أفضل الأدوات للدفاع عن الثقافة الأمريكية هي الحوار
كيف تدافع عن المملكة العربية السعودية إذا ما كان عندك حوار؟
يا أخي إذا ما كان عندك آراء ثانية
كيف هذا الصحفي المنحاز اللي نعرف أنه عنده أجندة
ما يقدر يهاجم المملكة العربية السعودية إذا كان عندنا حوار
وأكثر من رأي أصلًا صُدّر
بحيث أنه هو يقدر يلتزم مع الرأي هذا أو مع الرأي هذا
لاحظ الإعلام الرياضي عندنا
الإعلام الرياضي في المملكة العربية السعودية
هو الإعلام رقم واحد عربيًّا وأتمنى، إن شاء الله، قريبًا
خصوصًا من خلال توريد الكفاءات العالية هذه
كريستيانو رونالدو
وترى مو جيد في الكرة، أيش اسمه الثاني؟
نيمار، وبنزيما، عشان نرضي كل الفرق
نعم، يزعل علي واحد
فمن خلال الحوار شوف كيف الإعلام السعودي برز
نطقطق على بعض
وبنينا آلية حوار لا تتناقض مع تركيبنا السياسي
متصالحة مع تركيبتنا الاجتماعية، وفتحنا حوار جميل
وممتع وجذب الناس، وقدرنا نصدره
تدري من خلال الحوار أنا صدرت السياق السعودي
الحين الناس يتكلمون
و«عضوان الأحمري»
يقول لك: لازم تفتح السياحة عشان يجو؟
ليش السائح...
يفتح السياحة
عفوًا السياحة عشان...
ليش السائح لما يجي هنا يفهم السعودية؟
لأنه يرى السياق اللي نحن موجودين فيه
ويرى الحوار نحن اللي نعيش فيه، فيفهمنا
لما أنت تفعّل الحوار، أنت تصدر السياق
ترى المعجبين في أمريكا 99% منهم ما طبوا أمريكا
لأن الحوار الأمريكي صدر السياق الأمريكي
وخلاني أفهم بعض الأحيان قضايا أمريكية أكثر من الأمريكيين أنفسهم
واللي راح أمريكا الظاهر، وقابل أمريكيين نحن نفهم...
المسلسلات نفس الفكرة، لما تشوف «فريندز» ولّا تشوف...
كل شيء نعم
راح تشوف النقاش والجدل والاختلاف
أحسنت، وين الجدل والخلاف السعودي اللي صُدّر؟
بس هنا خليني، أبو سيف
بحاول برضو أتحدى الفكرة هذه شوي
أنا ما بعد وصلت للثالث بس تفضل
للركن الثالث
لكن جزئية الحوار أنت في أول حلقة كنت تتكلم على ضرورة
الاعتزاز بثقافتنا وبموروثنا وبمكوناتنا
نعم
احنا مجتمع حتى داخل الأسرة فيه موضوع طاعة الكبير
وطاعة الشيخ، وطاعة القائد حق المجموعة
أحسنت
وهذا مو بالضرورة خطأ، فهو عُكس على خطابنا
أنا هنا أجل بقفز إلى وظيفة الإعلام
نعم
لا، أجل آسف عشان ما نلخبط الناس
نخلي وظيفة الإعلام على جنب شوي
أجل ذكرني تكفى أرجع لها لأنها مهمة جدًّا
أبشر، فالركن الثاني
أنت قلت لي: الركن الثاني احنا ما عندنا ثقافة الحوار، وتوحيد الخطاب
وهذا مضر، ولا ينفع
عشان أنت لازم تجعل فسحة للخطاب الذي لا تتفق معه
من أجل تُصدر الكمية الهائلة من الخطاب اللي يمثلك
وشفنا الآليات هذه موجودة في الإعلام
وأنا مثلما قلت لك، اللقاء مع باسم يوسف، وإلى آخره
كدليل حاضر له
النقطة أو الركن الثالث
الإنجازات، وما أدراك ما الإنجازات
اللي يقابلها في الإعلام الأمريكي الفرص
يا أخي أعطيني شيء صُدّر من المملكة العربية السعودية كفرصة للعالم
شيء واحد
كل شيء إنجاز، أطول مبنى أو أحسن مدينة أو أكبر ما أدري أيش هو
ثم نصفق لبعض
أيش تتصور أيش (...)*؟
ماذا يعني لي أنا يا المتلقي هذا اللي قاعد ترسله لي أنت برى؟
في شيء كبير اسمه «استثمر في السعودية»
شيء كبير اسمه «روح السعودية» هذه كلها فرص
ممتاز، كيف صدرتها للآخرين؟
جزئيًّا أنا يمكن أعطي اعتبار لـ«روح السعودية»
لأنهم بدّعوا شوي في العملية
والاستثمار كانوا مركزين يمكن على عملية الأعمال
القطاع الخاص
لكن تكلم عن الإنجازات الضخمة اللي بنيناها في السعودية
المشاريع الضخمة مثل «البحر الأحمر» و«نيوم»
حتى في المنطقة ككل، أطول مبنى، وإلى آخر
هل صدر هذا كفرصة للعالم ولّا إنجاز للبلد؟
إنجاز
وماذا يعني للآخرين؟
يا أخي، شوف كيف الغرب صدر إنجازاته كفرص
لأننا نحن كالبشر، إنك تستطيع أنت
إذا أنت موهبة، يا أخي حياك الله
في نموذج احنا سويناه سميناها «نموذج آي تي يو»
«الاستثمار في المواهب والمستخدمين»
إن شاء الله، أن يطلع فيه كتاب لطيف أتمنى أنه يخلص
والمحرر يخلصني في أسرع وقت ممكن
ابحث وشوف الخطاب السعودي
يمكن عندنا «استثمر في السعودية» وعندنا السياحة
إلى حد معين يمكن نجحوا في التسويق للسعودية
لكن إذا الإنجاز ما يخاطب المستثمرين بشكل واضح جدًّا
وما يخاطب المواهب بشكل واضح جدًّا
وما فيه رحلة واضحة إن كيف هذا يصل إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
وما يخاطب المستخدمين مستهلكي السلع والخدمات السعودية
في الخارج، ويوصل له رسالة
نحن إعلامنا فاشل
فقياس أي إعلام حكومي، أنا لو ألخصها لأحد الشباب
قِسها على المحاور الثلاثة هذه
كيفك مع المستثمرين؟ كيفك مع المواهب واستقطابها؟
كيفك مع مستخدمي المنتج السعودي داخليًّا وخارجيًّا؟
حتى لما أتكلم عن 2030 وبرامج 2030
كيف تسويقها للمستثمر الداخلي والخارجي؟
كيف سوقتها للمهارات والمواهب الموجودة في الداخل والخارج؟
وكيف سوقتها للمستخدمين في الداخل والخارج؟
وهنا أنا أعرف نجاح أي عملية اتصال
قد ينجح في ركن، ويفشل...
بس يمكن أبو سيف الدافع فيها
وأنا مو بضرورة أتبنى هذا الرأي
لكن قاعد أحاول أتخيل وجهة النظر هذه
في أن أنت عندك صورة ذهنية عن السعودية
متراكمة على مدى سنوات
في حراك غير عادي يحدث
تحتاج توصل للعالم
بأن ترى انطباعكم أو نظرتكم للسعودية ما هي دقيقة
احنا عندنا تمكين المرأة اللي أنتوا تقولون: أن احنا نظلمها
عندنا مشاريع تنموية ما احنا بس بلد بترول
وعندنا «إكس وواي وزد»
فيمكن الدافع وراء تسويق الإنجازات
هو محاولة تغيير الصورة الذهنية أو تصحيحها
عشان ينتج عنها فعل مثل السياحة أو الاستثمار أو غيرها
هنا احنا فشلنا في تسويق الإنجاز
احنا عندنا لنا مو لهم
فأنا أيش دخلني
أيش دخلني أنا
ماذا يعني لي هذا يا رجل؟ يقول لك الأمريكي
مثلما كان يقول «عضوان الأحمري» أنه روح قل لأي أحد
عندنا تطبيق «أبشر» يطلع لك تأشيرة
أو إقامة الخادمة في دقائق
يعني هذا إنجاز محلي بحت عظيم نفتخر فيه لكن الآخر ما يفرق معاه
شكرًا حتى مشاكلنا أن نروح نصدرها للآخرين حليناها
عندك قيادة المرأة مسألة داخلية صح ولا لا؟
حليناها
سواءً قضيتنا خطأ أو صح
(...)* الموجود أنا مع من يقول أنه خطأ
ليش تمنعه أصلًا من الأساس؟ لكن هي شأن داخلي
تروح الأمم المتحدة، وتعلن أن خلينا المرأة تقود
وتصفق لعمرك؟ ليه؟
ليش تقدم اعتذار للآخر؟
أنت لاحظت، ارجع لجذر المشكلة
من قاد الإعلام غير السعوديين
ومثّل للسعوديين بأننا نحن نلحق الآخر
واصبروا علينا إلى أن نصير مثلكم
أثّر للأسف على حتى كثير من السعوديين في إدارة خطابهم مع الآخر
إني لازم أروح أقول له: أنا بلحق معكم، وبجي معكم واصبروا
ومثلما قلت هذا مكلف جدًّا لنا نحن كدولة مركز
فأرجع، يطول لي عمرك، للركن الثالث
نحن يجب أن نصدر فرص للعالم على المسارات الثلاثة اللي قلتها لك
وهذا تعريفي لعملية النجاح وأركانه الثلاثة
هل أروح مثل الأمريكيين
وأخلي خطابي حقوقي بس، وأفتح حوار بحري
وأتكلم عن فرص بشكل مطلق؟
هذا غير صحيح، لأن اللي صار في أمريكا لما تكلموا عن الخطاب
انهارت المسؤوليات، وأفرطوا في عملية الخطاب
وهنا مدخل لنا على وظيفة الإعلام
الإعلام اللي يعمل في الديمقراطية العلمانية
يختلف تمامًا عن الإعلام اللي يعمل داخل الملكية في الثقافة الإسلامية
مختلف تمامًا، وهنا الخلل في الوظيفة
هل تعريف الإعلام واحد؟
هل وظيفة الإعلام أنه هو يكون السلطة الرابعة؟
وإنه الكلب المراقب؟
وأنه يمثل الأطراف الآخرين؟
في أي سياق سياسي واجتماعي؟ هذا غير صحيح
وللأسف هذا عتبي على كثير من المفكريين عندنا في الإعلام
وظيفة الإعلام الموجودة في الغرب
إفراطهم في عملية الحقوق، وإفراطهم في عملية الحوار
أدى إلى أن الرأي الشاذ يُؤخذ، ويُضرب به السواد الأعظم
إلى أن فُتّت المجتمع تفتيت هائل جدًّا
ماتت الوطنية
وما بعد الوطنية، أيش معنى انتماؤك؟
تعال الحين هل هذا ممكن ينسجم معنا؟
لما يجي واحد يشغل الإعلام
ويقول لك: أنا لازم أفتح الحوار بطريقة
وأبحث عن الرأي الشاذ، وأضرب به
ثم يجي يقول لي: أحد القواعد الأساسية
«كلبٌ عضّ رجل» ليس خبر
«رجلٌ عضّ كلب» هو الخبر
ثم يبدأ في عملية أنه يأخذ الرأي الشاذ جدًّا
ويضرب به السواد الأعظم
هل هذا مفروض يكون وظيفة إعلامنا؟
ولّا الحفاظ على التجانس والحوار داخل تركيبتنا السياسية وقيمنا الاجتماعية
أنا أرى إن وظيفتنا الآن في الإعلام
وهذا تصوري أنا
أن 30% يفتح حوار إيجابي داخل الإطار السياسي والاجتماعي
ويحافظ على التجانس
و70% إذا أنت شاطر في إدارة الحوار، تصدّر وتدير حوار مع الآخر
ومختلف معك اختلاف حقيقي
يعني توقف عن اصطناع الاختلافات بطريقة مزعجة جدًّا
لا بد تصنع اختلاف عشان تقدم لي حوار
لأنك حاكر نفسك داخل البلد
يا أخي الحوار موجود في الخارج
اطلع وقابل
ما شاء الله، منهم «عضوان الأحمري» اللي أكثر من رائع
يبرد القلبه، ما شاء الله عليه، في حواره مع الآخرين
ونحتاج أبطال أكثر من هذا
فهذا الخلل الوظيفي إنك تجي في وظيفة إعلام
وفي سياق سياسي مختلف وسياق اجتماعي مختلف
تحاول تطبقه عندنا في نفس الطريقة
وأنا أسميهم أن عندهم نفاق صحفي
لا يمكن تأخذ وظيفة من سياق سياسي واجتماعي مختلف
وتحطه عندنا
برامجهم اللي يقدمونها هم اللي توافق قيمهم هم
احنا ما يمكن نجيب مسلسل نسميه «مودرن فاميلي»
وهم ما يمكن يجيبون برنامج الصبح اسمه «نور على الدرب»
مختلفين
عندهم إشكال في تصالح بين الرأسمالية والديمقراطية
الإعلام هناك مملوك حقي
«سي إن إن» و«فوكس» كيفي
أنا اللي أسويها بالطريقة اللي أبيها
فهنا التوازن، إذا اعترفنا إن وظيفتنا مختلفة
30% تجانس وحوار مثلما نجحنا في الحوار الرياضي
و30% هي الشاطر روح دير الحوار مع الغرب، ما شاء الله، كل الهجوم
فلو بلخصها، أبو سيف
أنت تقول التجربة الأمريكية في تسيّد المشهد الإعلامي
مُرتكزة على ثلاث أركان: حقوق وحوار وفرص
نعم
جزء من ضعفنا ناتج عن أن احنا مركزين فقط على الواجبات
وعلى توحيد الخطاب وعلى الإنجازات
وفي الأخير أنت تقول نعتمد على الأركان الثلاثة في التجربة الأمريكية
مع تعديلات تناسب سياقنا الاجتماعي والسياسي
أحسنت
هذه أظنها جيدة وواضحة
الآن خليني أروح لجزء آخر يهمني أسمع رأيك فيه
لأن في سقراط قاعدين نحاول نوثق التحول في كل القطاعات
في بعضها قدرنا، وبعضها ما وصلنا لأحد يساعدنا فيها
لكننا عارفين أيش التحول اللي صاير
وفي قطاعات ما احنا عارفين أيش نوع التحول
قطاع الإعلام من القطاعات اللي بالنسبة لي
مو عارف أيش مشروع السعودية في الإعلام
ولا فيه مستهدفات أو استراتيجيات مكتوبة في هذا الأمر
سألت ضيفي «عضوان الأحمري»
وكان يرى من وجهة نظرة، لأنه هو ما يمثل أحد رسمي
لكن كان يرى بأنه مشروع السعودية الإعلامي
هو الرهان على الفرسان الثلاثة الرابحة
المجموعة السعودية للأبحاث والإعلام، إم بي سي، وروتانا
من ابتسامتك أنا متخيل الإجابة الجاية ما راح تكون متفقة مع «عضوان»
أنت لازم تسبب لي مشاكل
لا ما أبغى أسوي مشاكل مع أحد
لكن أبغى أعرف قراءتك أنت للمشهد
ما هو مشروع السعودية الإعلامي؟
هذه يبيلها رشفة من القهوة
ما تراهن على أحد الحين في الإعلام
الإعلام بالديناميكيات اللي قاعد يشتغل فيها ما يزال...
الأجهزة الإعلامية عبارة عن اتصال داخلي
شوف أنت في الشركة عندك واحد موظف
مختص في الاتصال الداخلي هو اللي يسوي لك الإعلانات
ترى جاءنا موظف جديد، وترى عندنا تشريع جديد
ترى فيه قانون جديدة معين
ترى عندنا الحفلة الفلانية تعالوا، حياكم الله
فطور الخميس
هذا إعلامنا عبارة عن اتصال داخلي فقط
وزارة الإعلام أنا تصوري، ولا أستهدف أشخاص، يطول لي عمرك
قاعد أتكلم عن وظيفة الإعلام وهي عبارة عن اتصال داخلي للسعودية
وكل الأبطال اللي في القطاع الخاص بشكل عام
أنا ما أدري هل هو ضبط ذاتي؟
ليش هم مانعين أنفسهم من إنهم يحتكون مع الآخر؟
ليش مانعين أنفسهم من تصدير الخطاب؟
لا يمكن الرهان على هذول أنه هو يصدر الثقافة
أنا لا يمكن أن أرهان على إم بي سي أو روتانا
بأن هي اللي راح تصدر الخطاب السعودي لي كدولة مركز
ليش؟
لأنها فشلت في تمثيلي أنا يا السعودي أصلًا
فشلت إنها تشبهني اللي هو أقل حتى مني، أنا كسعودي
ناهيك عن إنها راح تقدر تصدر الخطاب
للأسف وجود الغير سعوديين في الإعلام
خلى الإعلام يمارس وصاية علي أنا يا سعودي
يكلمني أنا في قيمي
المفروض إنك تكون السعودي الأفضل هو الذي لا يكون مثلما أنت عليه
بل يكون مثلما نراه، وأنت عليه
فيه وهم عند اللي يسعون لتطوير الإعلام
فيه عندهم وهم إن التطور الأخلاقي تطور خطي
لأن للأسف إن التطور المادي برضو خطي
يعني اللي متطور مني ماديًّا هو أعلى مني أخلاقيًّا، هذا الخطأ
كيف تقيم تجربة «رشاش»؟
شفته ولّا ما شفته؟
شفته
أنا ليش ضربت مثال «رشاش» لأن هذا
لأن هذا السؤال تحديدًا، ليش مسلسلاتنا ما تشبهنا؟
طرحته على «أبو خالد» في حلقة سابقة
مع الشيخ «وليد إبراهيم»
وكانت إجابته، بأن الفترة الماضية ما كانت عناصر النجاح موجودة
من الآن وصاعدًا راح تشوف أشياء مثل «رشاش» وطالع
لا، ما نبي مثل «رشاش»
ليش؟
حرقان فني يا رجل، صدق
أيش ملاحظاتك عليه؟
قنوات يوتيوب من شبابنا السعودي
يطلع محتوى أقرب مني من اللي قاعد يصير هناك
مثل أيش؟
مثل يا أخي المشاهد
أنا شفته، وما قدرت أكمله
أنا كنت أحاول، حتى بعد اللقاء
كنت أحاول أخلص المسلسل الكامل، وشفت الفصل
أنت فهمت أنه ما يبغى يعكس الواقع بطريقته الحقيقية
لا تشوف الأخطاء الموجودة مقارنة بالإمكانات
ضخ بميزانية  «أفلام تايتنك»
وإنتاج محتوى ضعيف جدًّا على مستوى مسلسل «خلك معي»
مو معقول يا رجل إني أضخ المبالغ الضخمة هذه جدًّا
وتطلع لي مسلسل
عشانك خليت كابرس يصدم ولّا ينقلب
فقلت لي: إنتاج ضخم
ما زالت الجدران بالفلين، والنَص مكتوب من غير سعوديين
واللكنات الغريبة اللي قاعدة تجي
مرض يا رجل، أنا قلت لك حرقان يجيك فني، وأنت تطالع
أنا قد أختلف معك لأنني شفته
وأكيد فيه مساحة للتطوير
لكن ظنيته هو أقرب شيء لنا
قصتنا وممثلينا
ممثلينا كلهم؟
نعم الأبطال
الأبطال فقط، والباقي؟
أقصد «الجود من الموجود»
أنت تتكلم على قطاع لسة بدأ
يا أخي الموجود أكثر من الجود اللي نبيه منك
ليش محاصرهم للحين؟
يعني ما عندنا ممثلين سعوديين قاعدين يتكلمون؟
ما أنت قادر تسوي حوار يمثلنا كسعوديين؟
بالله ما تحس...
كم كلية تمثيل وإخراج عندنا في السعودية؟
توها مُنشأة الآن
طيب، وين خريجينها عشان تقول أخذ منهم؟
اللي قاعد يصير الآن في وزارة الثقافة شيء أكثر من رائع
أنا مبسوط جدًّا
كل أركان التمثيل الثقافي من أزياء والأكل والسينما والمسرح
اللي قاعدين يبنونه شيء خرافي جدًّا
الآن الإمكانات التقنية اللي قاعدين نبنيها أكثر من رائعة
لكن انتبهوا للخلل الاستراتيجي
إذا أنت ما راح تصدر حقوق كونية
أقصد بالحقوق الكونية، هل احنا جمعيين ولّا فرديين؟
كيف نرى قصة العائلة عندنا؟
ليش ما ترويها بالتصور السعودي؟
إذا أنت تروح تلتصق بالغرب وتحاول تقدم قصصهم من خلال منصاتنا
احنا ما سوينا شيء
إذا أنت ما تروح تفتح حوار بالإنفاق الضخم والبنية التحتية الهائلة
اللي قاعدة تبنى الآن
وصدرت السياق السعودي
اللي يخلي الجميع يفهم الثقافة السعودية، ويؤمن فيها
وحتى يمكن يقلدها
ولّا راح نفشل إذا أنت استمريت في نفس الطريقة
إذا خليت هذه المنظومة اللي قاعدين نبنيها
يديرها غير السعوديين باسم التدرج
راح ندخل في الدهليز مرة ثانية
والله يعيننا، على عشرين أو ثلاثين سنة ثانية
نتأخر فيها في تصدير الخطاب السعودي، حرام
عشان كذا أقول لك: تيتانيكس، وما تعدينا القريات
ولو برجع لسؤالي، ما هو مشروع السعودية الإعلامي؟
ما في مشروع سعودي إعلامي
«دافي الشريان» الله يجزاه الخير، وأمسي عليه بالخير
قال: ما في مشروع
أنا أتصور إن سمو سيدي محمد بن سلمان
لو أنه أدار الملف هذا لرأينا عجيبة أخرى
يمكن ما يزال يحتاج نضوج قليل جدًّا
ويمكن نشوف البنية التحتية اللي قاعد تبنيها وزارة الثقافة
لكن الإدارة الإعلامية ما وصلت إلى الحد المطلوب
أنا دائمًا أقول: لم أرى في عيوب الناس عيبًا
مثل نقص القادرين على التمام
وهذا ينطبق علينا احنا
أنا سعودي رجل ضخم، ومفتول العضلات يتفاخر بأنه يحمل خمسة كيلو
هذا الإعلام حقنا
ولو أخذنا الأركان الثلاثة، وجينا نطبقها اليوم كروشتة
ولّا بالعربي يقولون وصفة علاجية
اعطني أمثلة أيش نوع الحوارات اللي نقدر نخوضها مع الآخر
في سياقنا الاجتماعي والسياسي، لنا قيمنا
أيش الفرص اللي تعتقد إنها موجودة عندنا، ونقدر نصدرها؟
أيش الحقوق الموجودة في سياق ثقافتنا ونقدر نصدرها؟
أبى أعطيك مثال الآن عن الحقوق اللي يُمكن تصديرها
شوف الحوار الأمريكي الآن بين اليمين واليسار
اليمين ينطبق معنا تقريبًا تمامًا في رؤيتنا الاجتماعية
دور العائلة ودور الأم ودور الأب
وكيف التماسك، ودور الدين، واحترام الديانات الأخرى
«جوردن بيترسن» و«بين شابيرو» هذا الصهيوني، وإلى آخره
تجد هذا الطرف الحوار اليميني
أنا أقرّب لك على شيء موجود الآن لأن السعوديين ما سووه
تلقى هذا الخطاب اليميني يمثلنا، تقريبًا، تمثيل رائع
في الإطار الأخلاقي
ونتصادم بشكل حاد جدًّا على المستوى الفكري
شفنا الصهاينة وانصدامنا في غزة
فشوف الحوار اليمين مع اليسار في الإطار الاجتماعي
هذا ممكن خطاب احنا نتبناه
كنا نتكلم الحين احنا عن حرب باردة جديدة اجتماعية
وللأسف عندنا كثير من المختصين في الإعلام
ما هو بقادرين يستثمرون فعلًا اصصدام أو الحرب الباردة الاجتماعية
بسطها أبو سيف، أيش نوع الحقوق اللي عندنا، ونقدر نصدرها للعالم؟
أنا أنظر أن احنا نرى أن الجمعية حق المجموعة يغلب حق الفرد
وإن الفرد اللي يتكلم عن حقوق الفرد دون المجموعة
هذا نوع من أنواع الأنانية
وهنا تضاد واضح بيننا وبينهم
كيف سوقت الجمعية؟
كيف سوقت إن الفرد أنه هو اللي يضحي المجموعة وهو الصالح
وليس العكس
اللي يشيل نفسه ويقول: أنا ما أسبب عبء على الآخرين
احنا ما نقول، لا بالعكس، التكافل اللي بيننا هو المطلوب
صدرتها في قصة؟
آسف لو قاطعتك، أذكر كنت أسولف مع واحد فرنسي
فرنسي لكنه من أصول أفريقية لكن أنه فرنسي
في وحدة من المدن الفرنسية
في الصيف كنت أسولف معه، ولما عرف أني من السعودية
هنا يختلف مع اللي أنت تقول له
تكلم عن «نيوم» وتكلم عن كريستيانو
ففيه إنجازات هي اللي شدته أنه يعرف عن السعودية أكثر
بعدين قال لي: أتمنى أزور العلا
ممتاز
قلت له: ليش؟ قال: في الحقيقة...
هو يعمل في محل بيع بالتجزئة
قال لي: في الحقيقة أتمنى أنقل، وأعيش في السعودية
قلت له: مرة غريب
قال: يا أخي أنا من أصول أفريقية، وعندنا طريقة تربية مختلفة
أنا ما أقدر اليوم أربي ولدي في بيتي
بالقيم اللي أنا مقتنع فيها
أنا ما أملك هذا الحق
لكن أنا أعرف إنكم أنتم لسة ما تزالون بمفهوم الأسرة
أقدر أنا أكون قريب من أولادي
وأقدر إني أفرض أو أغرس القيم اللي أنا مؤمن فيها في عيالي
أحسنت
فمفهوم مثل مفهوم الأسرة
اللي قاعد اليوم يذوب ويتلاشى في مناطق كثيرة في العالم
وهو شيء مؤلم جدًّا
أنت ما يزال عندك هذا المفهوم
مدعوم بثقافة محلية، ومدعوم بقيم شرعية ودينية
هذا بحد ذاته كفيل بأن الناس أو مجموعة من الناس
تجي وتستقر في بقعة مثل هذه البقعة
هذا الحوار بين استخدام الميزة التنافسية الحالية
الموجودة في المملكة العربية السعودية
وخلق ميزة تنافسية جديدة
هذه ميزة موجودة
هذه موجودة لكن ما تم استثمارها بطريقة صحيحة
أنا أعرف موهوبين، علماء يعني يتنافسون دول على إنهم يستقطبونهم
يقول: أنا مبسوط هنا في السعودية
وعاجبني نمط العيش السعودي، وأحب جو العائلة
وأنبسط بالحميمية الموجودة
هذه لم تسوق
هذه سوقت؟
أبدًا
ولّا يوقا وتمغّط؟
ليش ما سُوّقت هذه؟ ليش ما يجذب الموهوبين؟
هذا اللي عنده التفكير
يا رجل الحنين الموجود في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الحين
لقيم العائلة
أنا أشوف حتى مقابلة لواحد من تكساس
يقول: لم أتصور يا أخي أن التكاتف الموجود في السعودية بهذه الطريقة
هل هذا تم تسويقه؟
يا رجل الخطاب السعودي محتكر في قضيتين خارجيًّا
الطاقة والأمن، شيء محزن
كل الخطاب الموجود عندنا بشكل قوي جدًّا
هو منحصر في الآليتين هذه
أرجع للميزة التنافسية الحقيقية للسعودية
أنت هل أدركت ما هي السعودية؟
وما هي الميزة التنافسية، وبدأت تصدرها لبرى؟
ثم شفت أيش عندنا من قيم اجديدة اللي تقدر تصنعها، وتجذب الآخرين؟
ليش ما استثمرت في الموجود حاليًا؟ مو هذا الموجود
أنا أشوف دكاترة ومدرسين، وسووا معهم مقابلات
جاؤوا هنا يا أخي وانبسطوا، حس بالحياة
الحنين اللي في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية للثمانينيات
موجود الحين في السعودية
التقييم الأسري والتكاتف الأسري الموجود
والمسؤوليات اللي يؤمن بها كل فرد
مو التنصل من المسؤوليات الموجودة، والاحتفال بالحقوق
موجود عندك هنا في السعودية
تعال هنا تجي...
يا أخي فيه تراتبية عالية عندنا احنا في النضوج
احنا سافرنا برى، وشفنا كيف الفردية
اللي مسمينها بالاتكال على الذات
هذا يمكن في حوار صار بيني وبين واحد من الأمريكيين
كنا نتناقش أنا وإياه
يقول: نحن أفضل منكم
يقول لي: في إنتاجية الفرد احنا أحسن منكم
قلت له: كيف؟
قال: أنا اللي أقوم وأغسل ملابسي، وأصلح شغلي وأعتمد
أنتوا لا
أنتم تسيطرون على المرأة
وعندكم هرمية في السيطرة على بعض
قلت له: غير صحيح
نحن ندرس في الاقتصاد إن كل واحد يعمل في ميزته التنافسية
نحن كعائلة كخمسة أشخاص
إنتاجيتنا أعلى من خمسة أفراد عندكم
إذا كل شخص في العائلة يعمل فيما يجيد
واحد يجيب الأغراض، وواحد يغسل، والثاني يطبخ
واحد يشتغل، ويجيب الدخل
لما تجمع مجموع ناتجنا نحن كخمسة أفراد يتجاوزكم أنتم كخمسة أفراد منفردين
نحن إنتاجيتنا كمجموعة أفضل
ولّا إنهارت المبادئ الاقتصادية كلها
مَن سَوّق هذه كقيم اجتماعية؟
ولّا ما زلنا نسوق الفردية واحترام حق الفرد؟
في جوع للمسؤولية في العالم الغربي مخيف جدًّا
أنا أرجع للحرب الباردة الموجودة الاجتماعية
ترى العالم قُسم يمين ويسار اجتماعيًّا
حتى الدول اللي كانت في اليسار والحرب الباردة الحقيقية
اللي هي الصين وروسيا
اللي كانت حرفيًّا في اليسار كشعوعية
الآن اجتماعيًّا في اليمين
هي ضد التفسخ الأخلاقي، ومعنا في خندق واحد نحن السعوديين
ومعنا الآن يمكن نص الولايات المتحدة
وأقول لك تتركز أكثر حتى في الجنوب
إن هذا أصلًا أخلاقيًّا
إذا عرفنا نفرق أيش الحروب اللي احنا نخوضها
معاك في خندق واحد
هل أنت استثمرت في العملية هذه؟
أو أدركت القيمة المتاحة لك لتقدر تصدر خطاب السعودي
وقيمك أنت كسعودي من خلال الحوارات الموجودة في العالم؟
ونتكلم عن حرب باردة في العالم كله على المستوى الاجتماعي
مَن استثمر في هذه؟
مَن المنصة الإعلامية اللي صدرت؟ إم بي سي أو روتانا؟
هي اللي راح تصدر...
ولّا ما زالت عندها أجندة معينة؟
وتمارس أن المفروض أنت اللي تتغير عشان تكون أفضل؟
وين التمثيل في الإعلام هذا الموجود؟
متى وقفت هذه القنوات ضد إعلام آخر، ومثلتنا احنا تمثيل حقيقي؟
في الإطار الاجتماعي
خلي الاقتصادين والسياسيين، هذه وظيفتهم
لكن اجتماعيًّا، هل هي مثلتنا؟
ولّا دائمًا تجي بالآخر وتضرب فيك أنت
وشوف هذا المثال المفروض يُحتذى به
وين وصلنا؟
وصلنا في سؤال جميل من أحد الأصدقاء
يتكلم على موضوع التواصل الحكومي في مرحلة التحول
الكلام اللي فات كله سياق عام
كلام عام عن الخطاب السعودي بشكل عام
أو الخطاب العربي أو الشرقي
الآن احنا راح ندخل بشكل محدد
التواصل الحكومي في مرحلة التحول
كل جهاز حكومي يعيش قصة تحول على مستوى خدماته
على مستوى أنشطته، وعلى مستوى أعماله
فكثير من الأشخاص لا يرون أنه يقوم بواجبه على أكمل وجه
والدليل بأنك مثلًا تشوف حدث معين
ولّا خبر معين ترند في تويتر
وصوت عالي جدًّا وزخم
ينتهي اليوم، وما أحد فاهم شيء
تلاقي مشاريع يُعلن عنها
ثلاث أو أربع أو خمس سنوات ما عاد في أي خبر بعد الإعلان
نعم
تلاقي أكثر من ممارسة في موضوع التواصل الحكومي
زميلنا «عضوان» اعترض على مبدأ الاستعانة بالمشاهير
بأن الكثير من التواصل الحكومي
في مرحلة معينة ما أعرف إذا هو استمر ولّا بدأ يخف
كان يعتمد على المشاهير للحديث عن خدماتهم وإنجازاتهم وتحولاتهم
أبغى نقرب الصورة على التواصل الحكومي في مرحلة التحول
بدون أسماء عشان ما ندخل في الدهليز مع أحد
الممارسات اللي سواها الغير سعودي في إدارة الإعلام
بحيث أنه يوجه للحكومة
نفس الممارسات الموجودة عند المؤسسات الحكومية
الاحتفالات هذه بالإنجازات موجهة للحكومة
ما هي موجهة للمواطن
عشان كذا تلقى انفجار ضخم جدًّا كأنه احتفال
وإيصال الإنجاز لصانع القرار ثم يختفي
واللغة المستخدمة موجهة لصانع القرار
ما بُسّطت للمواطن
ما احتفلوا فيها للمواطن، وفيه جوع للإنجازات
تجده يتحدث...
أنا أقول فيه شيء غريب عندنا في الحكومة
نحن في خطابنا موجه لنا سوف وسوف
يا أخي التزم بتاريخ
يا أخي حط وقت، قُل اليوم الفلاني راح أسوي الشيء هذا
هل لقيت خطاب حكومي واحد موجه للشعب فيه التزام؟
أختلف معك، وأقل لك جُل الخطابات الحكومية مؤخرًا
من يوم بدأت الرؤية مرتبطة بتواريخ
وهذا أهم ما يميزها، حتى لو فوتت تواريخ
لكن المرحلة الأولى من «البحر الأحمر» راح تبدأ عام كذا
المرحلة الأولى «أوشن» راح تكون كذا
أنا ما أقصد «المشاريع العملاقة» ولا أتكلم عن المشاريع
أجل؟
أنا أتكلم عن المؤسسات والوزارات، خلنا في الإطار هذا
أعطيني شيء وقالوا نحن نلتزم في التاريخ الفلاني
راح نعطيك يا المواطن
خلنا التصنيفات راح نصل دوليًّا في واحد واثنين
لكن في الخطاب الموجه للمواطن
هل وجهوه بطريقة سلسة بحيث أنه هو هدفه فعلًا إبراز إنجاز المواطن؟
خلني أعطيك مثال حدث مؤخرًا يمكن قبل أسابيع
موضوع التحول الصحي
صحينا يوم، ولقينا تويتر مولع كله على موضوع التأمين الوطني
أفضل تأمين لا يمكن تلاقي مثله في العالم
وكلام عام
تبحث عن تفاصيل ما تلاقي
كان فيه تواريخ
وهذا ردًا على النقطة اللي أنت ذكرتها في منتصف 2024 يبدأ
نهاية 2026 تنتهي المرحلة الأولى
كان في مراحل زمنية ممتازة
ما أحد فاهم شيء، وانتهى اليوم ذلك بزخم ترند
ما أحد فاهم شيء
اليوم التالي جلسنا مع معالي وزير الصحة
كانت جلسة أكثر من رائعة
شرح الموضوع بطريقة كانت واضحة جدًّا وسلسة
ومفهومة وأثرها إيجابي جدًّا على البلد والقطاع
وبالتالي على المواطن
لكن في مرحلة متأخرة بعدما ينضج القطاع نفسه
فأنا قاعد أقول المشروع واضح وعظيم ومميز مثلما شرحه الوزير
ليش ما وصل للناس؟
ليش هذا الشيء احتجت أنا إني أروح وأجلس مع الوزير ثلاث ساعات
عشان أستوعبه
ليش التواصل حول هذا الموضوع ما قدر يوصل للناس
اللي أنا أخذته من وزير؟
وهذا مجرد مثال ينطبق على أشياء كثيرة
هي واضحة عند المسؤول لكن ما وصلت للمجتمع
هذا التواصل، الخلل أنه عدم فهم رسالة
أنت تقول ما فهمت أصلًا احتياجاته
فالرسالة اللي قاعد تعطيها أصلًا ماهو مرتبط فيها؟
أنت أيش قاعد تتكلم عنه؟
نحن سنحلل مسألة التأمين الآن، ونقدمها
أيش هي بالضبط؟ هل هي بطاقة الآن بروح المستشفيات كلها؟
لو طلع، وقال تقدر تروح المستشفيات كلها بالتاريخ الفلاني
وهذه البطاقة راح تصدر
أسهل من التصريح هذا أيش هو؟
ليش التعقيد؟
هو بيتكلم عن إرباك السوق
والقطاع الخاص كيف راح يتحرك، وشركات التأمين
هو في رادار، وأشياء كثيرة جدًّا
لا تصرح بتصريح مُبهم وتسوق لإنجاز للحكومة أكثر من المواطن
ثم تقول: ليش الناس ما فهمت؟
لأنها عبارة بسيطة تقدر تقدمها للناس
فأول مشكلة إن التواصل الحكومي
يرمي ملامة عدم الفهم على المواطن
والملامة عليه هو أنه هو ما فهم المواطن
ثاني مشكلة بأن التواصل الحكومي
يُركز على الإنجازات اللي المسؤول يبغى يشوف أنه أنجزها
فهو يسوق للحكومة، ما يسوق للمواطن
الثالث؟
في مشكلة ثالثة في التواصل الحكومي؟
ما أتصور أن بسلاسة اللغة وبساطتها
وعود، للأسف احنا نحاول نحتفل بإنجازات قبل
أنتوا شيلوا كلمة سوف، وأمورنا طيبة
قولوا: تم افتتاح تم
نعم وأنت تحتاج فترة تمشي فيها عشان تبني مصداقية
أنا ما ودي أدخل لأنها هي مياه عكرة جدًّا
أنا أشتغلت في القطاع هذا
وشفت شباب، ما شاء الله، عليهم يشتغلون ليل ونهار
ترى الإجهاد الموجود في القطاع الحكومي
والركض اللي قاعدين يسوونه الشباب شيء أكثر من رائع
يا أخي ما سمعنا احنا عن الاحتراق الوظيفي قبل خمس سنوات
قاعد نشوفه بعيوننا
يعني فيه شغل أكثر من رائع
ولكن؟
ولكن أنه ما ينعكس على المستخدم النهائي أو المواطن
ليش؟
لأنك ما تفهمه ولا درسته
وكأنك تحط نفسك في موقف إنك أنت اللي تبغى تطوره
معقولة ما في، يا أبو سيف، ولا نموذج واحد من التواصل الحكومي؟
أنا أبى أعطيك تواصل حكومي يمكن نموذج...
جيد عشان نضرب فيه مثال
ممتاز، وفيه الجيدين ترى
أنا أتكلم عن الركبة...
الركبة اللي توجع
بس أنا أقصد جزء من شرح الموضوع للمستمعين
إننا نقول لهم: شوفوا المثال هذا كيف...
أعطيك مثال معالي «توفيق الربيعة»
اشتغل في التجارة، أيش سوى؟
مكّن المستخدم، وفتح القنوات، وحط تطبيق في مخباك
إذا أنت زعلان واحد ما حط التسعيرة قدم شكوى
لا ولك جزء بعد من الغرامة مكافأة
حط الكرة في ملعبي، أنا خلاص سكت ورضيت
لأن هو مكني، وما خدمني
ما قال لي: لا أبشر بروح أطاق أنا معهم، وبوريك فيهم
حط الكرة في ملعبك، وقدم الشكوى
راح لوزارة الصحة
حتى هو لما يطلع يتكلم مع المواطن
ما عمره يتكلم نحن فعلنا وأنجزنا
من أجلك أنت ترى نبغاك تسوي كذا عشان حرصك...
وشفنا الخطاب الموجود
أكثر من رائع
يا أخي شكرًا إنك تكلمني عني مو عنك
شيء ثاني، يا طويل العمر، راح وزارة الصحة 937
مرة أخرى مكّن المستخدم
وزارة الاتصالات؟
عفوًا وزارة الصحة، مكّن المستخدم
أنا أتذكر دخلت وكالة سيارات أصلح سيارتي
بعدما طلع «الربيعة» من التجارة
وقلت له: يا أخي خلاص الحقوق، والله لأقدم عليكم شكوى
رد علي قال: ترى «ربيعة» راح
هذا وكالة سيارة؟
وكالة سيارات
كان ودي لو كنت أعرف ألعب كونق فو ذاك الوقت كان تفاهمت معه
لكن اللي صار...
بس عفوًا مرة ثانية أيش نوع التواصل اللي صاير هنا؟
يعني أنت ضربت مثال بالدكتور «توفيق الربيعة» والنعم
نعم، لكن أقصد أيش التواصل اللي صار؟
التواصل أنه فتح قنوات لي
بنى أذاني لكي يسمع، بدل مكبرات صوت اتجاهي أنا
فتح هذا وصنع وصمم أذن
روح ودُر على الوزارات، هل هو يبني مكبر صوت
ولّا صنع أذن كبيرة وقاعد يسمع المواطن؟
تأكيدًا على كلامك أنا قرأت كتاب معالي الدكتور «توفيق»
اللي هو «الوقوف على أطراف الأصابع»
يتكلم عن فترة الجائحة
وذكر هذا المثال تحديدًا 937
بأنه كان وسيلة لفهم وين نقاط الألم الأكثر إلحاحًا؟
فيقول: وصلنا مرحلة كنا نتلقى 150 ألف اتصال في اليوم
ومن خلالها كنا نتنبأ وين النقاط الحرجة فنوجه الجهد والتركيز عليها
فهي وسيلة استماع ممتازة لأولويات الناس
ومن خلالها يمكن يقدر يوجه خطاب أو يوجه تواصله
أو يوجه فريقه التنفيذي لمعالجة تحديات معينة
هذا يقودنا إلى موضوع «أنسنة» الخطاب الحكومي
أنه شوف الخطاب الحكومي دائمًا يتكلم عن إنجاز
وصدع روسنا بالإنجازات، ولّا عمره باع الجهد
مع أن البطولة ما تصنع إلا في الجهد
لما يجي الحين يتكلم، ودائمًا تلقى الوزارة الفلانية
أو المؤسسة الفلانية الحكومية
لما تخاطب الجمهور تتكلم نحن فعلنا وأنجزنا وحطينا
لكن ما أحد باع لك الجهد، والخطأ غير مُغتفر
أسميه الخطاب السوبرماني
الإعلام عندنا لما يسوق الحكومة للـ...
لحظة عفوًا، شلون ما سوق الجهد؟
أيش الجهد اللي تقصد لازم يسوقه؟
أعطنا مشاريع فشلت، ليش فشلت؟
هل هو معضلة كبيرة؟ عشان أنا أتعاطف معها يا أخي
طيب جابك الله، هنا بنجي نطرح على حالة
أبغاك تلبس قبعة المسؤول
لأن سهل، وأنت قاعد على الكرسي هنا تقدر تأخد راحتك
بس البس قبعة المسؤول
وقل لي مثلًا في حالة مترو الرياض
حالة أحبها أنا، وأسولف عنها كثير
كان أنجح مشروع تواصل حكومي من وجهة نظري في تاريخ السعودية
دول تتكلم عنه
لكل الشرائح
ورسومات الأطفال محطوطة على الحفريات
المجتمع هم اللي يسموا الحفارات
كل حفارة تخترق الحي، سكان الحي، وتقدر تتابعهم في تويتر
ويوتيوب وفي كل مكان
فجأة المشروع مر بتحديات تشغيلية
وكانت فترة غير واضحة، والإجابات غير واضحة
فقرروا ويقفون التواصل
الخطاب السوبرماني هو اللي دخلنا في الجدار
قرروا ما يحكون أبدًا
في هذه الحالة أيش المفترض يطلع يقول؟
يقول: ترى احنا متعثرين احنا آسفين؟
آسفين فشلنا للأسباب التالية
ووقتها بتُعفى أنت من منصبك كمسؤول عن المترو
تحمل مسؤوليتك يا أخي
لا الكلام سهل، مستعد تضحي بمنصبك عشان...؟
طبعًا، لأنك إن ما ضحيت بمنصبك
راح تتحاسب أنت بعدين عند الله، سبحانه وتعالى
هذول الناس كلهم في رقبتك
أيش مهم؟ المنصب يعني
يا أخي قدم مسؤوليتك، فشلت أنا آسف
هل فشلت وأنا أفضل واحد يستطيع يعالج المشكلة؟
نحن ندعمك ونوقف معك ونصفق لك
مو لازم أحد ينتصر ترى، على المقياس هذا
الخطاب الإعلامي دائمًا يقدم...
يا أخي الحكومة ضحية الإعلام
لأن الإعلام قاعد دائمًا يقدمها كسوبرمان
القادر على فعل كل شيء، ولكنه لا يفعل كل شيء
القادر القوي الذي لا يفشل وإذا فشل تلقى الإعلام اختفى
وفقدنا المصداقية
يا أخي تكلم عن الفشل
فالمشاريع المتأخرة والمتعثرة أيش أفضل...
وضح لي، هل هو تحدي ضخم، يا أخي أنا أقدر
يا أخي أنا كنت بجيك، وكُسرت رجلي
لا، ليش ما جيت؟ يا أخي كُسرت رجلي
المفروض أزوره، وأعطيه هدية، وأتحمد له على السلامة
يا أخي أعطيني فرصة أتفهمك، يا رجل، ما فيه
ثقافة الفشل
أصلًا الفشل هو الي يصنع التأييد
يا رجل تخيل حتى سوبرمان في أفلامه الآن هذه
لو أنه ما يكون ضعيف ضد المادة الخضرة هذه الكريبتونيت
كان ما تعاطفنا معاها
كان قلنا: يا أخي هذا القوي جدًّا المفروض يحل مشاكل الدنيا كلها
لكن نعرف أنه يضعف، وندري أنه يحب فلانة، ولازم ينقذ فلانة
لكن لما يجي يقدم الخطاب الحكومي
يقدمه على أساس أنه هو السوبرمان
وحط الحكومة بشكل قوي جدًّا في موقف محرج
أن ما عاد تقدر تعترف بالـ...
فلما يصير الوضع الطبيعي اللي هو تأخر أو تعثر
ما يقدرون يحاكمون لأن التوقعات عالية
لأنه خلق منه سوبرمان، وهذه الطريقة العجيبة جدًّا
يا أخي كيف تجد تعاطف عندي؟
لا بد يكون هناك خطاب متوازي بين الجهد والإنجاز
يا أخي بِعني الجهد، ترى أنا أقدر الجهد حتى لو فشلت
على مقاييسكم أنتم يا آليات الخطاب الإعلامي الآن
معناها الشهيد اللي ما ينتصر يروح النار، هل هذا صحيح؟
معناها دوري أنا، شوف تهميش دور المواطن
حتى في الخطاب الحكومي، وحتى في 2030
أيش دوري أنا كمواطن في 2030؟
مُتفرج؟ فقط مطلوب مني التأييد؟
لأنه ما باعني الجهد، ما باعني المعاناة
ما باعني...
ما باع أيش دوري أنا؟
ما باعني أيش راح ينفعني في القريب؟
وما هو النفع البعيد؟
ما باعني التكلفة القريبة والتكلفة البعيدة عشان أنا أعقد صلح معاه
لكن أنت اجلس على الكرسي هذا
وتفرج على سوبرمان كيف يسوي المعجزات
هل هذا راح يصنع تعاطف؟
تبينيي أقول أين مصداقيتنا ذهبت؟
يا أخي كيف أنا أتعاطف معك إذا أنت الخارق، متى تفشل؟
الآن احنا فيها
سمو الأمير فيصل بن فرحان، شفت مشهده؟
مَن لم يتعاطف معه بالسعودية؟
بطل، لأن عملنا واحنا عارفين اللي اشتغل فيه
أنا نفسي تعاطفت معه بشكل قوي جدًّا
باع إنجاز ولّا جهد؟
جهد
جهد، أيش صار؟
أكثر من رائع، نصفق له عليه، شكرًا جزيلًا
فهل فيه جهد تم بيعه في الخطاب الحكومي؟
هل فيه اعتذار واحد تقدم وبُرر؟
بحيث أننا نفهم الرجال كان راح يجينا لكن رجله كُسرت
مشينا خلينا نساعده ونعينه
فهذه التراكبية، الأخطاء المركبة عندنا في الإعلام
هي اللي أفشلتنا في بناء إعلام يمتلك مصداقية قوية جدًّا
يمكن من الأسئلة برضو اللي وصلت مرتبطة بالحسابات الرسمية
فيه...
احنا هجمنا هجوم كامل على القطاع الحكومي
مو احنا، أنت لحالك، لا تدخلني معك
أنا قاعد أطرح أسئلة فقط
تفضل، طال عمرك، أنا بس عشان...
قبلما تسأل السؤال
نركز على الركبة اللي توجع
شكرًا، تفضل
في أسئلة على موضوع أن فيه مشاريع ذات هيبة
أو صورة ذهنية معينة أو قدر معين
تبغى تحافظ عليه فتلجأ إلى لغة رسمية أو لغة حكومية
مثلًا الحساب الرسمي للرؤية
حساب يمثل رؤية وطن، واستراتيجية وطن
طبيعي أنه يأخذ الصبغة الرسمية
اللي ما فيها أي نوع من التبسط اللي قد يضعفها
من وجهة نظر شريحة من الناس
فهذا يدفعهم إنهم يستخدمون خطاب رسمي جدًّا
أدى إلى أنه ما أذكر في حياتي شفت أحد تداول تغريدة
أو شارك في مجموعات واتساب لقطة شاشة
لتغريدة من تغريدات حساب الرؤية
اللي يمكن يكاد يكون الملايين يتابعونه
لكن صداه أو تأثيره يكاد يكون معدوم
لأنهم مضطرين يحافظون على...
أنا قاعد أحاول أحلل
يحافظون على رمزية المشروع بأنه الخطاب لازم يكون رسمي
أيش تعليقك على هذا النوع من الحيرة
ما بين إنك أنت تتبسط وتفقد هيبتك
وما بين إنك أنت تحافظ على كيانك بلغة رسمية لكنك تفقد تأثيرك؟
شوف أنت ما أنت محكور في قناة واحدة
أنت قد تحافظ على قناة واحدة إنها تحفظ...
أنا شلون أجيب لك مثال
العلا على سبيل المثال فيه حساب رسمي يحكي عن الهيئة الملكية
وفيه حساب عن الأنشطة اسمه «لحظات العلا» عفوًا
هذا يأخذ صبغة مبسطة وفعاليات وأنشطة
لا بجيب لك مثال أنا
صح، العلا أنت ما تحبه عشان اليوقا، ممكن نأخذ مثال ثاني
أبي أورطك معهم
طيب، لا
أمزح
أنا أحب أشخاص كثيريين يعملون هناك
وهم عارفين مشاكساتنا مع بعض
يمكن ما قيل أكثر مما سيُقال هنا، وهم أعلم به
وهم أن الهيبة تضيع إذا غيرت الحوار هذا غير صحيح
أنا دائمًا أستخدم مثال سمو الأمير، رحمة الله عليه، سعود الفيصل
أروع المتحدثين
الله يرحمه
لما يتحدث كلنا نسمع، قال نكات كم مرة
هل فقد هيبته؟
لما كان ينكت لنا من يُبارزني، ومن يسابقني؟
هذه أصلًا عملية الطرح إنك تفكك الخطاب
إنك تقدر تتكلم أحيانًا خارج الإطار، وتكسر من حدية الخطاب
هي اللي تبني الارتباط العاطفي بدل الارتباط العقلاني ونحبه
لكن ما فقد هيبته
تبسيط الخطاب لا يعني فقد الهيبة، وهذا أكبر وهم
وأنا أعطيتك مثال: سعود الفيصل، رحمة الله عليه
أنه كيف يتكلم معنا بالطريقة هذه
وجبناه على السياق هذا
وقاعد يتطور الخطاب السعودي العاطفي عندنا، يا الله لك الحمد
بشكل أفضل يعني حتى بيع الجهد الحين قاعد يزيد عند الأفراد
ولكنه يكاد يكون معدوم عند المؤسسات
لأنهم يخافون من اللوم
فاللي أقوله للجهات الحكومية هذه
يا أخي لا، ما أنت مجبر إنك توحد الخطاب
موجودة شركات العلاقات العامة يجيبون أشخاص يتكلمون بالنيابة عنك
وتستخدم وسائل أخرى، وتبسطها
وتبين أن الرسائل هذه مستهدفة، ما هو عذر
ولا أنت تمثل نفسك يا المؤسس
أنت لازم تعكس الرسائل اللي تناسب جمهورك
لا تطلب من الجمهور هو اللي يتأقلم عليك
نفس المشكلة
لكن إذا أنت ما فهمت ما تلزمني أصلًا
الخطاب يصل محددًا لناس معينين، هذا خطأ
هذا مشروع وطني
شيء أنت تؤمن فيه، شيء أشوف عيالي فيه في المستقبل
شيء أفرح فيه يا رجل
2030 سوقت السعودية أنها تتغير
يا رجل، كنا احنا على، الله لا يغير علينا
إلى ثقافة «إن الله لا يغير ما بقومنا حتى يغيروا ما بأنفسهم»
صار الطبيعي هو التغير بدل التكلس اللي كنا عايشين فيه قبل
فيه تحرك أكثر من رائع والجميع يعرف في العالم أن السعودية تتغير
لكن يمكن احنا ما وصلنا إلى مستوى نعرف في أي اتجاه تتغير
وما هو دورك أنت يا المواطن في هذا التغيير
ما هي الكلفة التي يجب أن تتحملها كمواطن؟
ما هو دورك أنت الذي خارج السعودية؟
كيف تستفيد وأنت خارجها؟
ما هو * في 2030؟
لكننا نجحنا في بيع أن المملكة تتغيّر
لكن كيف نقدر نبيعها للآخرين؟
هذا ما قدرنا نسوقه بشكل قوي
برضو من الأمثلة اللي أنا أشوفها جميلة للتحول في التواصل
أبى أسمع رأيك فيها، إذا لك رأي فيها
في فترة 2019-2020
كان في نشاط غير عادي لصندوق الاستثمارات العامة
كنا نتعرف على هذا النشاط من «بلومبرق»
ومن «واشنطن بوست» ومن «رويترز»
ومن المنصات الأجنبية
تدخل موقعهم ما تلاقي شيء
تدخل حسابهم في تويتر ما تلاقي شيء
من 2021 وطالع راح تلاقي بأنه أفضل مصدر لأخبار الصندوق
هو حساب الصندوق
راح تلاقي هذا الكيان الجامد اللي هو عبارة عن مكينة فلوس
فجأة صار كيان له روح
شفنا وجوه الصندوق، ما هو فقط المحافظ
وشفنا موظفين أصغر منك، سهل يكون في أصغر منك
لأنك أنت مرة كبير في السن
لكن شفنا ناس في العشرينات موظفين جدد في الصندوق
يمثلون كل صفقة تعلن أو كل شركة تعلن
تلاقي يظهر وجه جديد يتكلم عن هذا الحدث
ففي تحول في التواصل في الصندوق لدرجة إني مؤخرًا
لما أحتاج أسوي محتوى عن صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
مصدري هو حسابه
وهذا تحول من كيان كنا نتابع أخباره من الصحف الأجنبية
إلى أن صار تويتر هو المصدر الرئيسي له
فشيء زي كذا هل تعتقد أنه مثال يمكن نحكي عنه
ولّا لسه عندك تحفظ؟
مثلًا أول مرة يُصدر لهم تقرير
العام الماضي صدر تقرير سنوي عن صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
مقارنةً مثلًا بالصندوق النرويجي اللي تدخله اليوم مباشر
تشوف حجم استثماراتهم، وعدد الشركات اللي هم داخليين فيها
تصويتهم في كل شركة هم مستثمرين فيها في الجمعية العمومية
وأيش كان تصويتهم على قراراتها؟
هذه كلها متاحة ومنشورة في موقع صندوق الثروة
أو الصندوق السيادي النرويجي
فاحنا بدأنا من نقطة مرة متدنية
في صندوق الاستثمارات العامة في التواصل
اليوم واصلين مرحلة جيدة في موضوع الأنسنة، مثلما أنت تفضلت
وفي موضوع الشفافية والتواصل مع الناس
فأيش تعليقك؟
هو نضوج رائع
أنا انطربت من لحظة يمكن مرة قبل تقريبًا شهر
وهي كلمة سمو سيدي «لا أهتم»
أعجبني هذا التحول، أيش تسميه؟ غسيل رياضي؟
ما يهمني، كيفك، وفكر باللي تبيه
وهذا التحول الرائع اللي أنا قاعد أقدم السعودية
كالسعودية بوجه سعودي بالطريقة السعودية
بالماركة السعودية، وبآلية السعودي
تبيه حياك الله، ما تبي توكل على الله، نقطة
وهذا اللي مفرحني جدًّا أنا منتشي من العملية هذه
أخيرًا يا رجل أن قيلت هذه الكلمة، لا أهتم
تبي؟ حياك الله
وهذا في الإطار الاقتصادي
أنت الحين لما تدرس تصور السعودية في جميع المنافذ الإعلامية
لما تروح المنافذ الإعلامية السياسية
تجد التصور عن المملكة العربية السعودية سلبي
لما تروح المنافذ الاجتماعية
لما تروح المنافذ الاقتصادية تجد التصور عن المملكة العربية السعودية إيجابي
يكاد يكون الكل إذا ما هو 90%
واحنا أدركنا اللغة هذه لغة الأرقام نشتغل معهم ومشروع وبثقافتي أنا
تبي رأس مالية، حياك الله
ما تبي، توكل على الله
واللي أعجبني في الخطاب الاعتذاري
للأسف ما زال في بعض المؤسسات الحكومية مختفي تمامًا
أنا مو قاعد أقول إني قاعد أقدم
أنا راح أقدم مشروع أحسن منك
وشفنا حتى، وراح نقدم مشروع يعكس ثقافتنا السعودية
وشفنا أكثر من تصميم تم رده، وأُعلن هذا في الإعلام
أنه لا يتسق مع الثقافة السعودية
وخليني أتكلم عن الركبة السليمة الحين
هذا أحد الأركان الجميلة اللي تخليني فعلًا أنا أقول
أو الأمثلة الناجحة على هكذا يقدم الخطاب للسعودي
وأنا أنتظر من يُمثل المملكة العربية السعودية خارج السعودية
أن يكثر من كلمة أنا لا أهتم
هذا ما أؤمن فيه، هذه قيمي أنا تبيها؟
«وَجَعَلْنَاكُمْ شُعُوبًا وَقَبَائِلَ لِتَعَارَفُوا»
مو لتتجانسوا، لتعارفوا
أنا لدي هذا، وأعرف ما لديك
أحترم ما لديك بفكرك
واحترم ما لدي غصبًا عنك، تبي ولّا بكيفك
فهذا الطرح القوي الجريء
لاحظ حتى حوارنا الحين
حوارنا احنا في المنافذ الإعلامية العربية قوي جدًّا
أنا أعيد «عضوان الأحمري» قوي جدًّا
لكن لاحظ لما نروح الإعلام الغربي، يا أخي الحدة هذه تختفي، ليه؟
يا أخي صادم، رد عليه رد قوي جدًّا
وإن شاء الله، أن هذا الخطاب الاعتذاري يبدأ يتآكل
ونبدأ نكثر من أنا لا أهتم
من ضمن أسئلة الناس
هذا سؤال يمكن قريب وبعيد من موضوعنا
اليوم مع الشبكات الاجتماعية صارت هي وحدة من أهم وسائل التواصل
فنلاقي في نشاطات مختلفة للوزارات
ولقادة الوزارات اللي هم الوزارء
فتلاقي في وزير ما له أي ظهور إطلاقًا
ومعتمد على المنصات الرسمية هي اللي تتكلم
فيه وزير عنده ظهور، ولكنه مربوط بنشاطه الرسمي فقط
إنجازات الوزارة ومشاريعها وأنظمتها وقوانينها
فنشاط الوزير هو مرتبط فقط بعمل الوزارة
وفيه نوع ثالث: حسابات الوزير تغطي شؤون خاصة
أو نشاطات خاصة اجتماعية وترفيهية وفكرية وإدارية وقيادية
فمن بين الثلاث نماذج هذه
أيش تشوف النموذج الأنسب لدور الوزير في هذه المرحلة؟
على حسب نوع الوزارة
إذا كانت الوزارة «جي تي سي» أو إنها تخدم المواطنين بشكل عام
قد يطالب من الوزير أنه يكون متفاعل أكثر مع الأفراد
إذا كانت هي مؤسسة تخدم أفراد
وإذا كانت مؤسسة تخدم أفراد يمكن، ومؤسسات في نفس الوقت
قد يكون في المنتصف
وإذا كانت مؤسسة تخدم فقط مؤسسات
قد يكون أنه مختفي أفضل يخدم إعلاميًّا
أنا كمستشار الآن إعلامي أتكلم
الإشكال هو أنه أيش راح تبيع لما تقدم نفسك كشخص؟
هل هي أنسنة للخطاب الحكومي؟
هل هو راح يعرف الجهد؟
هل تقدم أنت مصدر إلهام للآخرين؟
ويجب أن تكون حذر جدًّا لأننا نحن جمهور لا يرحم
فعلى حسب، أنا أراهن على القدرات الشخصية للفرد
إذا كانت قدراته الشخصية للفرد أنه يستطيع إدارة هذا الملف الصعب جدًّا
بحيث أنه يتعامل مع الجمهور بشكل مباشر
مين التجربة اللي تعتقد إنها تجربة جيدة؟
أرجع لـ«الربيعة» أنا أرى بلا منازع أنه نجح
عاد الناس يقولون: من قصد ولّا من غير قصد
مرسومة ولّا غير مرسومة
أنا لا أعلم، لكنه فعلًا هو نجح
فيه أشياء ثانية ساعدته، شخصيته والكاريزما، ويشبهنا كلنا
دقن وثوب سادة وغترة مريحها
ما في محاولة إبهار إذا صح التعبير
وسلاسة في الطرح
ما فيه مصطلحات صعبة
بساطة الطرح يمكن، وأنه يشبهنا خلتنا ننسجم معه بشكل قوي جدًّا
ناهيك على أنه فعلًا يفتح المسار، ويرمي كرة في ملعبك
رمي الكرة في الملعب أسهل من إنك تروح تحارب من أجل
المستخدم أو المستفيد
في «عبدالعزيز آل غنيم الحقباني» في «عكاظ»
كتب بعض الجهات المغرضة أو المحرضة
تحاول ضرب الثقة بالإعلام السعودي
بهدف الوصول إلى ترسيخ المقولة الكاذبة
إعلامنا فاشل
وهذا أمر يدركه كله ذي لُب
ولكن ثمة مغردين في تويتر نياتهم حسنة
ينقلون تلك الشائعات المغرضة عن إعلامنا دون تمحيص
فلا ينجر المغرد المواطن وراء تلك الجهات الخبيثة بتغريدة
قد تكلف الكثير من الجهد لتصحيحها
خصوصًا إذا استغلتها بعض المؤسسات العالمية الغربية
والمغرديين الحاقدين
نحتاج إلى تعزيز الثقة بإعلامنا لمحاربة تلك الجملة الخبيثة
إعلامنا فاشل
خصوصًا مع التطورات الحالية والمستقبلية للإعلام السعودي
الذي يعتبره الكثير من النقاد ذوي الخبرة الإعلامية
أنه الأقوى عربيًّا وإقليميًّا
أنت جهات مغرضة أو محرضة، أيش تصنف نفسك؟
أصنف نفسي رجل حريص جدًّا ومنزعج
ويكاد يصاب باكتئاب من وضع الإعلام اللي عندنا
أنا زعلان جدًّا
وإذا ضربت الثقة في إعلامنا...
يا أخي مو ثقة في إعلامنا
ما هو فريق الهلال والنصر إنك تطالبني بالولاء للمؤسسة
مطلوب من هذه المؤسسة إنها تخدمني أنا كمواطن
ترى إعلام هو
أنا ليش ولائي للمؤسسة هذه؟
أنت تقيمني أنا كمواطن صالح ولّا طالح
بحيث إني اتفقت مع الوزارة الفلانية ولّا لا؟
أنا قاعد أقول لك هذه الوزارة اللي قاعدة تخدمني
والمفروض تصدر صورة الإعلام فشلت بالأسباب هذه
إذا تبي تفتح نقاش حقيقي أنا حريص
أنا أشوف اللي قدامي مريض
هل حبي له أنا أقول له: لا أنت ما أنت بمريض
خلاص امشِ وموت، ترى العلاج موجود هنا
بس لا تأكله، أنا عشاني أحبك أنت ممتاز
يا أخي، انصر أخاك ظالمًا أو مظلومًا
لا تجيني إذا جيت أنصر أخي، وهو ظالم
وأرده عن الظلم تحطني أنا غير صالح
فهذا شيء غير مقبول
فأنا أفصل بين عملية التأييد والتصحيح للمؤسسات
أو الجهاز وجد لخدمتي أنا كمواطن
أبو سيف، السؤال الختامي بعد هذا الطرح
ما شاء الله، الشيق جدًّا
أعتقد أنك تقدر تلخص لنا أبرز تحديات التواصل الحكومي
وأبرز توصياتك لو في اليوم مسؤول يسمعنا
أيش بتكون توصياتك أو مقترحاتك له؟
أول شيء لازم ندرك التراكم الثقافي عندنا
اللي خلى بيننا وبين الصورة علاقة سلبية
وأنه ما زال موجود إلى الآن، ونتعامل معه بالتدرج
وأنا مدرك هذا الشيء، هذه أول مشكلة
الركن الثاني لا بد أن يُعاد صياغة وظيفة الإعلام
الغموض التشريعي
وإطارات الحوار اللي نقدر نتحرك فيها اللي مو واضحة
يجب أن تُعرف وتُقدم بطريقة واضحة جدًّا
عشان نستطيع إنتاج خطاب قابل للتصدير
الشيء الثالث، يطول لي عمرك
لا تصرفون فلوس ضخمة في التقنيات والبنية التحتية
واستراتيجيًّا نحن معدومين تمامًا
إذا ما صنعنا خطاب متوازي بين الحقوق والواجبات
ويصنع حوار مُتسق مع هيكلنا السياسي والاجتماعي
وصدّرنا فرص لباقي العالم
الإعلام ينجح
فهذه تقريبًا تلخيص للنقاط الثلاثة
ولو راح أضيف عليها يجب أنسنة الخطاب الحكومي
وأنا أشكرك أنت، يطول لي عمرك
إنك استقبلت وزراء كثيرين هنا، ورمى الغترة
وقال قصته الحقيقية، وقدرت أفهمه، وأتعاطف معه
وأقدر موقفه
إذا ما جاءني ورجله مُنكسرة
أنا اللي أروح أزوره وأساعده
اللوم علي أنا مو عليه هو
فنتمنى إنهم يبدأون يأنسنون الخطاب، ويبيعون الجهد مع الإنجاز
وهذه تقريبًا الأربع نقاط
اللي أتمنى أن يتم معالجتها بأسرع وقت ممكن
شكرًا أبو سيف، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يعافيك
الله يبارك فيك
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لفهدة القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر بن الغانم في إدارة التصوير
وفي الإضاءة: إسماعيل شوقي
وفي تسجيل الصوت: عبدالرزاق المزي
وفي التحرير: أنس الخليل
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: رزان دهيثم
هذا بودكاست سقراط، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع